Ihr hört CAE-Technik-Kultur Gesellschaft, mein Name ist Tim Prittlaff und ich begrüße alle zur 225. Ausgabe von CRE. Ja, war mal wieder eine kleine Pause. Man muss ja mal ab und zu mal wieder drüber nachdenken.
Interessant ist und heute gehen wir mal in einen Bereich, den ich glaube ich so.
Gar nicht äh abgedeckt hatte, nämlich in die Landwirtschaft. Wobei das ist dann vielleicht auch erstmal nur so eine grobe Umschreibung. Darum soll's aber auf jeden Fall im Kern gehen, beziehungsweise der Fokus liegt auf.
Permakultur und was das alles so ist, das bespreche ich heute mit dem Falk, hallo.
Hallo Falk. Frank Falkner, wir kennen uns schon äh ziemlich lange und als ich sie kennengelernt habe.
Da warst du eigentlich so mit einer der äh digitalsten
Menschen, die ich so kannte irgendwie so, dann komplette äh Klaviatur hast du äh beherrscht so irgendwie jedes jedes komplexe Programm, was irgendwie auf deinem Rechner war, wird irgendwas mit Grafik zu tun hatte, äh noch ein paar andere Sachen. Hat sie mal voll drauf, total eine Digitalkarriere.
Irgendwann nicht mehr so richtig mit weiter.
Ja. Was ist denn da passiert? Ähm.
Ja, das ist eine gute.
Äh
Mich rückwärts auch manchmal. Also ist ein langer Prozess gewesen auf jeden Fall. Also sicherlich ähm sicherlich meine Tochter spielt da eine große Rolle. Ähm.
Ich habe ja nie auch war ja nie so das Stadtkind, habe nie so in der Stadt gewohnt und äh immer ein bisschen außerhalb und.
Habe dann auch Angst gehabt, da mein Heim zu verlieren und habe dann nach einem neuen Heim mich auch umgeguckt und ähm dann kamen ein paar Wildschweine und haben einen Garten umgegraben, an meinem Altenheim und ähm.
Ich äh wollte da nicht wieder Rasen machen und dann habe ich auch mal Weed angebaut. Die haben früher so äh,
Und det kamen irgendwie so alle zusammen ähm da ich hatte ja auch einmal ganz früh einen Podcast aber dann auch noch so über Leben ohne Geld geredet und da gab's dann auch einmal hin und wieder so,
Themen, was ja was Essen angeht und so und da bin ich dann auch über Böden wie
wo rät man Böden auf, gestoßen? Und das allet so hat nicht dann zur Permakultur.
Lenkt, sage ich mal.
Drei Bücher gelesen bei Waldgärten, wo auch immer schon das Name, Permakultur drin stand und aus meiner damaligen DJ-Karriere tatsächlich, gab's da welche, die aus Australien kamen, ähm.
Die dort in Australien Permakultur gemacht haben und über die bin ich dann wirklich auch über das Wort Permakultur gestoßen und die man dann so als.
So ähm ist, dann googelt man det, dann googelt man sich da rein und alles, was ich da gelesen habe, war wahnsinnig toll.
Ja, also äh war so das erste Mal, dass ich so eine Antwort auf viele Fragen dieser Welt äh gefunden habe. Also nichts Negatives, also wirklich äh wie kann man wirklich,
mit einem mit seinem Tun wirklich die Welt zum Positiven verändern so und es gab,
richtig konkrete Antworten. Also nicht nur so ein Geschwafel und nicht nur irgendwie so ein esoterische.
Irgendwas, sondern das war wirklich, hatte alles Hand und Fuß und ähm ich habe mir dann auch äh gleich ein paar Torens damals irgendwelche äh ähm Designkurse reingezogen von Bill Molison, dem ursprünglichen Gründer.
Ähm der dann lange keine keine Designkurse mehr gemacht hat. Ähm.
Als ich dann dazu kam, war der schon lange, allzu alt dafür und ja, da hat's mich so gepackt, das war so spannend. Oh, der.
Bemalen kann, richtig geil erzählen. Also der macht, hattet alten Storys verpackt und und du hast halt so eine Geschichte gehört und die Geschichte hat dir so viel beigebracht. Das war da habe ich gesagt, okay, das will ich, da will ich mehr.
Und da habe ich gegoogelt, wo kann man dann mehr lernen und dann kam ich aufs.
Designinstitut, Permakulturinstitut, ähm,
ähm in in Deutschland und die hatten bieten auch eine Ausbildung an vier Jahre.
Gesagt, ja, will ich machen, ja darfst du nicht, musst du erstmal einen Designkurs machen. Ja, hatte ich schon okay. Okay. Habe ich mir ja schon angeguckt im Internet, brauchst du ja nicht so, aber okay, machst du mal einen Design-Kurs und
gleichzeitig habe ich dieses Grundstück hier gekauft, also wo wir jetzt.
Was meinen die mit Designkurs?
Ja, das sind 72 Stunden Kurs, der ist auf der ganzen Welt 72 Stunden ungefähr zwei Wochen. Äh manche ziehen das auch über ein Jahr hinweg, aber es sind immer 72 Stunden wirklich Unterricht, ähm wirklich frontal, meistens frontal Unterricht und äh
da geht's darum, was in dem heiligen Buch der Permakultur, dem Designersmenual, so.
Geschrieben steht und das wird dann da nochmal ein bisschen mehr ausgeführt auch. Ähm und aus so einem Designkurs ähm wie gesagt, den kann man überall machen auf der Welt. Der ist thematisch im Prinzip.
Vom Inhalt her relativ gleich, hatten wir ein paar andere Themen mittlerweile, ist da so ein bisschen diverser geworden. Also bei manchen geht's ein bisschen mehr um Wasser, bei manchen geht's ein bisschen mehr um Sozial. Kommen wir gleich noch drauf. Aber im Prinzip ist das immer der gleiche Kurs. Ähm wenn wenn man da so einen Stempel hat,
dann egal, wo man den auf der Welt gemacht hat, ist das ähm ähm ja, hat man das gleiche Edelabend.
Mhm. Also du hast dich quasi um das jetzt mit deiner persönlichen Geschichte da äh einzugrenzen. Du hast eh schon immer quasi im Wald gelebt.
Ja.
Ist also ein totaler Waldmensch, ne, äh trotz dieser äh digitalen Nähe, dann äh,
die Wildschweine bist du sozusagen auf das Thema äh gekommen und hast dich dann halt da genauso reingefuchst wie vorher in 3D-Software und äh Videoschnitt. Einfach weil weil's dir sozusagen auch wertvoller vorkam.
Kamen wir wertvoller vor ähm war ja dann auch hier im Kongressen immer so auch dabei und so weiter und das ist halt super schön. Ich habe da sehr viele Menschen kennengelernt, die,
sich chaotisch organisieren und tolle Sachen machen. Ähm aber mir fehlt es so ein bisschen an Substanz, weil ich gemerkt habe, okay, diese Welt, der jetzt halt richtig scheiße, ne und es geht halt immer mehr,
immer mehr bergab und da habe ich auch ein also ich mag diese Natur. Ich mag auch
wie der Planet so ist, ja,
den zu sterben zu sehen, das tat mir auch immer mehr weh. Äh natürlich auch mit so einer Tochter, äh die neugeboren ist, noch ähm dabei, die auch eine Zukunft haben soll, auch eine schöne Zukunft haben soll und ähm
dat fehlte mir dann wirklich so ein bisschen in dieser ganzen ähm in dieser ganzen Computerszene so ein bisschen, ja toll, was alle machen und das auch,
und ähm sicher sind da auch ein paar coole Sachen damals bei gewesen, die Welt verändernd waren, aber nicht alles und viel auch nicht hinterfragt. Ähm Drohnen sage ich jetzt mal, habe ich erstmal beim
TCC kennengelernt, wo das hingegangen ist äh ne, haben wir auch gesehen und,
äh ja, da habe ich mich so ein bisschen bei der Permakultur.
Neue Zuhause gefunden, sage ich mal,
und ich bin halt aus diesen aus den 72 Stunden Kurs habe ich dann noch eingebucht ähm beim Jeff Lorten ist der Ziehsohn vor allem Bill Morrison werden wir heute noch öfter hören wahrscheinlich. Ähm und äh das so der Ziso und der hat auch seine Farben später übernommen
und den die habe ich um die Jordanien gemacht. Ihr habt auch noch einen anderen äh einen Grund dafür. Ähm der war sehr wasserorientiert.
Ähm und du gehst aus dem 72 Stunden Kurs total euphorisch raus und zwar alle. Also alle, die diesen 72 Stunden, es ist wie so ein bisschen, ne, so ein bisschen klingt so nach Sekte, um Gottes Willen, ne.
Ja, aber es ist wirklich du willst jetzt die Welt heilen.
Ist nicht so, ja, seit gleich, es ist äh äh das Erwachen kommt dann später und so, ja, aber äh äh du kommst heraus und,
will's anpacken und du willst jetzt irgendwie alles was du da gelernt hast, umsetzen. Ähm äh genau.
Das ist doch gut. Gehen wir nochmal auf den Begriff und vielleicht ein bisschen die Geschichte davon ein. Also der Begriff Pamakultur wurde von diesem auch aufgebracht das Ganze in den 70er Jahren, wenn ich das richtig.
Ja so Ende der siebziger ich habe jetzt nie genau das Datum, mache ich jetzt nicht, aber so Ende der Siebziger, der Permaculture one und Karma Kölschbach hat ursprünglich äh gelesen. Ich traue mir jetzt nicht den Vornamen auszusprechen.
Ähm Fuku Ucker waren Japaner, der.
Wasser-Nobu.
Genau. Äh der hat ein Buch geschrieben The Revolution, daran ähm beschreibt er ähm wie
nachhaltige Landwirtschaft möglich ist und zwar am am Beispiel vom Reis, dass man gar nichts machen muss und den Boden dabei aufbaut. Äh ist ein sehr kurzweiliges Buch.
Auch wirklich nur 100 Seiten oder sogar 50 oder das ist ein ganz dünnes Buch. Kann man wirklich sich mal generell als Lektüre reinziehen, ist so ein bisschen japanisch so mit ein bisschen
blumiger Sprache auch rundrum. Und der war aber selber Wissenschaftler, also da muss man dazu sagen, der ähm hat.
Genau, der hat ähm hat sehr wissenschaftlich hoch ist es auch angegangen und ähm genau The Wolson hat dieses Buch gelesen und gleichzeitig hatte er Suchwissenschaftler ähm,
hat einen Wissenschaftsauftrag gehabt und er ist, glaube ich, durch Tasmanien gerudert und sollte dort die ähm die Flora und Fauna studieren, so.
Da ist er ja auch her aus das mal.
Ja genau, ja und ähm.
Bei diesem Rudern so ein bisschen so eine Eingebung gehabt und gesagt, so Mensch, die Natur, die macht das aber alles ganz toll. Und mit diesem Hintergrund äh von dazu hat er,
rausgefunden, dass man daraus ja ein System erschaffen kann, was uns auch weiterhilft,
in der Landwirtschaft oder beziehungsweise auch Essen zu generieren in im Einklang mit der Natur.
Da hat er dann das und weil's einem wirklich Naturbeobachtungen waren geschrieben und später ist er dann auf David Holm Green äh gestoßen
rumgehen wollte, auch was lernen, also das waren äh seinen jungen Jahren wirklich ein Studium und ähm.
Hat dann aber äh zusammen mit Bill Mortison dieses Designermanuell geschrieben. Da gibt's dann ranken sich ein paar schwierige Geschichten. Äh das Verhältnis manchmal auch nicht das Beste war zwischen den beiden, äh weil er wirklich beim auch immer da,
hauptsächlich dastehen sollte, äh wollte, also als als Erfinder und so. War generell äh so cooler war auch ein
eine schwierige Person. Ähm.
Meistens ist mit so Leuten die irgendwas erfin.
Ja, genau. Aber äh auch Hombian steht mit auf dem Buch Titel mit vorne drauf. Also es war schon ein Gemeinschaftswerk am Ende des Tages. Genau.
Dieses Buch.
Nee also dies haben die äh zusammengeschrieben. Hat äh meines Erachtens glaube ich allein geschrieben. Er hat alleine geschrieben.
Nee, mir steht was anderes, aber.
Was anderes.
Die Wikipedia darüber.
Okay, ja, ist auch egal. Ja.
Aber das Prinzip ist halt.
Aber das Nanual ist dit äh zusammengefasste Wissen. Ja, also alles, was die beiden zusammen, Entschuldigung, äh als was die beiden zusammen rausgefunden haben, steht in diesem Perma Culture Manuel und darauf basierend ist auch dieser Kurs.
Mhm. Die Grundidee ist, wenn ich's richtig verstehe, also was dieser ja gebracht hat, war ja äh eine Landwirtschaftsmethode mit der.
Dem schönen Namen Nichtstun Landwirtschaft. Daraus leite ich jetzt mal so ein bisschen ab, wenn man's richtig macht
macht die Natur eigentlich alles selbst, mal so äh locker dahergesagt.
Was würdest du denn jetzt als den eigentlichen zündenden Gedanken hinter der Idee der Permakultur ähm bezeichnen?
Ähm hier von und.
Auch äh entwickelt wurde.
Nachhaltigkeit ist ja ist ja so ein ist ja so ein totales,
Wort derzeit, so. Das kann irgendwie alles meinen und auch äh nichts, aber das ist ja schon der Leitgedanke.
Gedanke nachhaltig Regeneration. Das war auch wichtig ähm äh ja also die Permakultur lernt von der Natur ähm wie sich Leben entwickelt.
Ich glaube, das ist so ähm und auch erhält,
Ähm das sind so die Kern, dieser Kern des Ganzen, ja. Also wir beobachten die Natur, gucken wie macht die das eigentlich, dass wir da gar nüscht machen müssen. Wir müssen keen Baum wässern, der wächst einfach vor sich hin und äh produziert dann noch,
Essen für hunderttausende Tiere und Spezies und danach geht der Baum ein und produziert wieder geilen Boden und der Boden wird immer besser und statt schlechter und eigentlich
macht man nix und das System erhält sich selber. Ähm das hat hat
die Permakultur versucht rauszufinden, wie funktioniert das? Also wie erhält sich Leben? Ähm natürlich spezifisch auf die Landwirtschaft am Anfang, weil Perma.
War permanent daher kommt das Wort ursprünglich.
Später hat man rausgefunden, ja das kann man auch noch an an auf andere Sachen übertragen. Es muss jetzt nicht unbedingt eine Landwirtschaft oder ein landbasierter Nummer sein. Ähm.
Deswegen sind wir jetzt dabei zu sagen, es heißt Termine ähm also wirklich eine nachhaltig selbst sich selbst generierende.
Kultur zu entwickeln, die auch in 1000 Jahren noch existiert. So.
Mhm.
So ein bisschen eine Kritik geht ja immer so ein wenig davon aus, dass derzeit alles nicht okay ist. Das hast du ja auch schon gesagt, okay Welt stirbt.
Was ist denn das Problem mit der Landwirtschaft äh so.
Die Welt, nämlich uns nicht. Ähm.
Ja, also wir machen viele dumme Dinge, sage ich mal, ja. Also wir haben irgendwann mal gedacht, ähm,
ist vielleicht einfacher, weil ich ich höre mal ganz weit aus, ja?
Ist vielleicht einfacher irgendwie unser Getreide anzubauen, als im Wald zu sammeln. Ja, wie das verstanden gegangen ist, ob das überhaupt so verstanden gegangen ist. Äh wird jetzt mittlerweile auch angezweifelt. Ähm vielleicht war es auch det Bier,
ja? Das ist meine neueste neueste Lieblingstheorie, dass wirklich das Bier dran schuld ist, dass wir angefangen hat ähm Gerste anzubauen. Ähm,
tatsächlich, also gibt's mittlerweile Belege. Auf jeden Fall haben wir das gemacht ähm dann auch festgestellt, okay, jetzt haben wir ja produzieren wir ja auch Zeug im Überfluss, was aber nicht das ganze Jahr wächst auch ziemlich dumm, äh müssen wir jetzt beschützen,
Ähm wenn man halt anfängt zu beschützen, ähm braucht man irgendwie.
Polizei und äh dann braucht man jemanden, der verteilt später. Ähm da deswegen brauchen wir starten,
ähm und äh so kann man im Prinzip das ganze Grundübel der gesamten Welt auf die Landwirtschaft zurückführen
ja? Weil der der Lord äh in Englisch ähm ist der der
Getreide verteilt. Ja das ist äh der Namenstamm kommt dort her, ja. Ähm das ist äh ist ziemlich ziemlich ähm.
Doof gelaufen, sage ich mal, aber dann,
Ja? Äh zusätzlich ähm ist es so, dass äh wenn wir jetzt erstmal ein Stück Land umflügen und ähm det machen wir, Colonia, also kolonisieren, es ist Landpflügen, ja äh.
Also spalten einziehen sozusagen, ja.
Genau ähm ähm machen wir erstmal ganz viel kaputt äh dadurch. Also wir
diesen vorher,
Boden öffnen wir ähm und äh setzen in der Erosion aus. Gleichzeitig äh zerstören wir dafür damit ganz viel Bodenleben, weil das von unten
von der Sonne geschützt und von den Umwelteinflüssen geschützt, liegt jetzt auf einmal oben. Äh,
zusätzlich holen wir auch eine ganze Menge Saatgut, was da ganz lange schon ganz unten liegt wieder mit nach oben. Und dann sehen wir da rein Weizen.
Jetzt mal als Beispiel, ob's nur Weizen, Mais, Graps oder irgendwas ist. Eine unserer fünf. Also wir haben ja eigentlich nur fünf oder sechs Staple-Foods.
Und ähm dann wundern wir uns, ja jetzt wächst dir das ja immer schlechter und.
Da so viel andere Zeug dabei, da wäre der Weizen ja nichts mehr zu sehen nach zwei Jahren
Ja, wenn man sie mal geht, ja wieder machen. Ja, das ist auch eine Natur wildet halt wieder begrünen alles, also auch was zwischen dem Weizen wächst, möchte sehr gerne, dass das wieder der Boden wieder bedeckt ist. Kriegen wir die ganzen Unkräuter, die Unkräuter ziehen aber auch
ähm gerade die Pionier und Kräuter ganz viel Energie aus dem Boden, sprich der Weizenwächs halt auch nicht mehr, Weizen wächst zieht auch jedes Jahr Energie aus dem Boden, was wir denn
abtransportieren
irgendwo essen und wo ganz anders deponieren, dann nehmen wir irgendwo wieder kacken gehen, so ne ähm und so wird der Boden immer ausgelaugt. Zusätzlich kommt der Wind und trägt dann auch noch diesen schönen Oberboden ab. Also wir haben's jetzt mittlerweile so
Das ähm fast 30 Prozent der Landwirtschaftsflächen wahrscheinlich in den nächsten 20 Jahren keinen Oberboden mehr haben. Also
werden weiterhin angebaut äh da drauf ähm auch ohne Oberboden. Ähm aber wie gesagt, also da
wird wird immer weniger Substrat, dass wir überhaupt noch möglich sind auf diesem,
Substratlosen Boden anzubauen, liegt halt an einer schönen Chemie.
Zweiten Weltkrieg ähm gab's ganz viel Phosphor vor allen Dingen auch für die Bomben und aus dieser Rüstungsindustrie entstanden halt die Düngerindustrie relativ bekannt,
zu sehr eng verbandelt ist mit und ähm.
Kippen wir jetzt da auf den Acker. Dit ist erst mal jut, das hat erstmal am Anfang am Anfang sehr, sehr toll ausgesehen. Wir haben das auf dem Acker gekippt und das,
kommen. Dann haben wir nochmal irgendwie noch in der zweiten Krieg, Vietnamkrieg geführt. Da haben wir Agent äh entwickelt, da hat man gesehen, oh.
Pflanzen kann man auch töten, auch spezifische Pflanzen kann man töten. Da kippen wir das doch auch noch mal darauf, so, ne, ähm dass dann natürlich auch noch alle anderen Lebewesen, die da drunter sind, auch mit eingehen.
Ist jene Sache und dass wir vor allen Dingen auch den Boden versalzen, weil das immer ein Salz, dieser chemische Dünger.
Ähm ein Riesenproblem. Also in Indien sagt man jetzt schon 15 Prozent der Landwirtschaftsfläche, ist nicht mehr benutzbar. Das heißt, es ist nicht mehr benutzbar für die nächsten 1tausend Jahre.
Versalzte Erde.
Versalzt. Das ist für immer da wächst nichts mehr drauf. Es gibt ganz, ganz wenig Pflanzen, die salzverträglich sind. Also wirklich kann ja weltweit an zwei Händen abzählen. Pflanzen, die wirklich Salz vertragen
Ähm und äh
allen dieser Flächen, die so ein bisschen weniger Regen abkriegen. Das Einzige, was wirklich dieses Salz noch auswäscht und auch regelmäßig auswäscht, deswegen sieht's hier bei unseren Feldern noch nicht so aus wie in Indien, ist der Regen.
Die letzten Jahre gesehen. Auch hier hört es langsam auf zu regnen,
den Punkt, dass wir dann dahin kommen, dass wir für tausende von Jahren, man sieht unsere Bohnen so kaputt machen, dass wir nicht mal mehr nicht mal mehr irgendwas pflanzen kann, ähm abgesehen von Essen, schon lange dann nicht mehr. Ähm.
Also da kommen wir relativ schnell gerade hin so. Warum regnet's dann auch nicht mehr? Und da ja auch da hat Ebblem alles sehr schön beschrieben. Na ja ähm wir kennen alle diesen Regen, diese diese Grafik, das.
Sonne scheint aufs Meer und dann verdunstet det und dann regnet es aufm Land ab. Das funktioniert so um hundert, 150 Kilometer vom von der Küste entfernt.
Regen, der weiter drinnen ist, ist immer durch Wälder.
Initiiert. Sprich, das regnet, 150 Kilometer von der Küste, äh in den Wald und der Wald verdunstet es wieder und dann trägt's den Regen weiter. So, jetzt haben wir aber Landwirtschaft und haben halt diese ganzen Wälder abgeholzt.
Und ihr kriegt das hier immer sehr schön mit, ich beobachte so so Regendinger und wo kommt mein Regen her?
Süd äh Westen. Südwesten ist Sachsen-Anhalt, ich weiß nicht wer immer schon immer durch Sachsen-Anhalt gefahren ist. Da gibt's keine Wälder mehr. Da gibt's.
Fährst du vier Stunden Auto und ja also oder drei, sage ich jetzt mal, ne, also wenn du über Land fährst,
äh ich bin letztens durch Thüringen nach Thüringen gefahren durch Halle und dann irgendwie von da zwischen Halle und der thüringischen Grenze kein weiter
Sieht man auch auf Google Maps, dass alle dann beschäftigt. Klar kommt hier kein Regen mehr an, kann nix verdunsten,
Gerade in den Nicht-Vegetationsperioden, klar kann auch das Gras beziehungsweise der Weizen ein bisschen was verdunsten, aber bei weitem nicht so viel wie so ein Baum. Sprich, es wird auch immer trockener auf der Welt, ja, obwohl wir eigentlich mehr Hitze haben und eigentlich mehr.
Mehr Regen in der Luft sein sollte, äh wird's trotzdem trockener, die Böden trocknen aus, versalzen die Landwirtschaftsflächen mehr. Zusätzlich haben wir mehr Wind, weil mehr Energie in der Luft ist durch den Klimawandel.
Wenn ihr so hat bestimmt jeder schon mal gesehen, da fährt einer mit seinem Traktor. Über so,
ja so einen trockenen Acker, so und dann kommt so ein Wind und dann hast du hinter dem Ding so eine Riesenwolke. Eine Tonne pro Hektar pro einmal rüberfahren ist weg. Für immer weg. Das heißt fast einen Millimeter.
Ja? Sprich, er fährt da,
In Brandenburg haben wir in schlechten Standorten 20 Zentimeter Oberboden. Dit ist schnell verschwunden. Wir haben hier Felder, wo äh wenn du da langfährst,
Und ähm da gerade kein kein Bewuchs ist, siehst du diese Flecken. Du siehst das schöne braune Erde und da hast du so weiße Flecken. Und wenn du dann den.
Was es da weiß.
Der Sand. Der kommt halt durch.
Ja ähm und dass der Oberboden weg und du kannst ja du kannst Weizen im puren Sand anbauen, geht schon. Wenn du ganz viel Dünger raufschmeißt, aber da mal wieder Ding und viel Dünger rauf wenig ähm.
Bist du ein Teufelskreis, der sich da im Prinzip daraus äh entgeht? Wie könnte man den denn rückgängig machen? Ich meine ist ja eigentlich sehr.
Sehr leicht nachzuvollziehen, dass man die ganze Zeit dort etwas hochzieht, was man woanders hinbringt und und und nichts landet wieder dort. So also müsste man äh eigentlich alles mit irgendeinem Bioabfall äh.
Abdecken.
Also klar, also wir haben ja.
Einen einzigen Kompost machen.
Haben wir jetzt auch biologische Landwirtschaft. Ähm ist halt weiterhin normaler Landwirtschaft mit dem Bio-Siegel. Ähm da haben wir zumindest schon mal nicht diese diese chemischen Düngermittel, ja? Ähm sprich da versucht man eine Art,
Kreislauf herzustellen, indem man dort äh wirklich ähm Dünger rauf äh,
kippt, ähm also meistens irgendwie welchen aus Großtierproduktion ähm Gülle haltrau aufbringt äh mittlerweile werden die Landwirte kriegen Kompost umsonst von,
aus der Stadt von der Biotonne. Jeder weiß, der springt in die Biotonne hin und so weiter.
Sehr viel Kompost ein. Ich war letztens äh aufm Kompostberg und habe äh und der hat gesagt, na wir haben hier noch diesen bio,
Kompost. Denke würdest, würde mir dir sogar umsonst geben. Ja, also normal bezahle ich sehr viel Geld für einen Kompost für einen guten Kompost.
Okay, gucke ich mir mal an. Ähm im Pure Tonnen Kompost sind 40 Prozent Plastik.
15 bis 40 Prozent Plastik. Also es ist wirklich, also das war furchtbar, wie das aussah. Das war wirklich, es war wirklich grauenvoll. Äh stärksten so die Störche, teilweise in diesem Bio.
Haufen Plastik rum. Und äh die bringen das auf die Felder. Die dürfen das auf die Felder bringen mit bis zu 15 Prozent Plasteranteile. Die sieben das noch mal, grobe Plasteteile kriegen sie noch raus. Aber wenn die das schreddern und so, bis zu 15 Prozent Blasteranteil dürfen sie auf die Felder bringen?
Wo kommt das Plastik her? Einfach aus.
Tonne ja in Leute schmeißen das halt mit rein.
Tüten, Bio, Bitplastiktüten.
Plastiktüten, also du hast halt deinen Biomüll mit einer Plastetüte und schmeißt den mit drauf. Ja ähm.
Wahrscheinlich dann auch, wa? Müll mit rein im Mixer, ist halt schwierig, kannst du nicht mehr aussortieren später
Äh sprich da landet im Moment sehr, sehr viel Mikroplastik auf dem Dings. Jetzt haben sie gerade herausgefunden, hm, Mikroplastik
ganz schlecht, weil es war jetzt lange Zeit nicht klar und jetzt rausgefunden Regenwürmer, Mikroplaster, killt halt Regenwürmer. So
und Regenwurm, der Regenwurm ist wahrscheinlich das wichtigste Tier der Welt. Äh muss man halt auch so sagen. Ähm
der Regenwurm kann halt nichts kann mehr Biomasse in Erde verwandeln als der Regenwurm, abgesehen von Pilzen vielleicht noch, ähm aber der Regenwurm ist wirklich richtig wie wichtig. Der kann nicht nur wie man's umwandeln, sondern er macht
besser die ganze Erdstruktur besser und so weiter. Auflockern. Das ist auch das, was wir jetzt so auf den großen Feldern ja gar nicht mehr haben. Also geben auf ein großes Feld Grab mal und suche mal einen Regenwurm.
Egal ob bio oder nicht. Also würde würden mit dir, dass du keine findest.
Anderen Kompost gibt es nicht in dem Sinne.
Doch da gibt's schon den Grünschnitt Kompost und so, also für mich hier für mein für mein Bio-Landwirtschaft,
nicht bio-zertifiziert ist, weil ich nicht so viel Kompass auftragen darf. Äh andere Thema. Ähm.
Für meine Landwirtschaft Kompost jetzt auch sehr sehr plastefrei ist, also da hast du mal einen kleinen Schnipsel noch drinnen, aber es ist ähm
weitgehend plastofrei, große Problem. Ähm aber nicht für die Felder, so viel gibt's da nicht,
also nicht so für auf so gut 200 Hektar ist ein kleiner Landwirt heutzutage, muss man halt auch sehen, ganz großes Problem,
ist halt auch alle kleinen Antworte aufgekauft zu haben. Ja, also damit
auch diese Innovation auch nicht mehr, ja? Es ist ähm also einer unserer Wege dorthin ist halt erstmal diese diese riesengroßen Korngramerate aufzubrechen, ne, die halt mit wenig Magde versuchen irgendwie äh trotzdem noch Gewinn zu machen und diese Preise auch nach.
Und so weiter und so fort und ähm ja und diese diese riesigen Flächen halt auch bewirtschaften, die halt bis dann Horizont, Weizen hast
Sieht halt schön aus auf einer Postkarte, ist halt
brutalst für die Biodiversität ähm ist ja nicht ne, ich hatte ja auch angesprochen, dass ähm dass man dann auch gegen die Viecher dann auch was getan hat, also nicht nur gegen die Unkräuter, sondern auch irgendwann hat man rausgefunden, okay, da gibt's,
Schädlinge, genau. Ähm ja aber Natur hat alle, ne, da sind wir ja wieder bei der Permankultur. Guckt mal, was macht die Natur gegen Schädlinge, ja? Vögel?
Zum also größte Schädlings äh Bekämpfung ist halt der Vogel, aber wenn du halt
über Horizont mäßig keinen einzigen Busch hast, wo so ein Vogel irgendwie nisten kann. Natürlich wird
dein ganzes Feld ist halt wie so ein Buffet für so Insekten. Da muss nur ein ein Ding befallen sein und dann kannst du dich einfach bloß drüber hopsen zum nächsten und dann kannst du irgendwie mehrere Hektarweise ab
essen äh und hast keinen keinen Feind irgendwie, weil die können ja nicht keine Nachkommen mehr zeugen, weil ja kein Nest das bauen können irgendwo. Ähm,
da gibt's tausend so ne Sachen, ne? Also Bodenbrüter, da fährst du mit riesen Maschinen durch. Äh alle Bodenbrüter weg. Ähm.
Und so weiter und so fort. Also es ist wirklich äh groß, Chemie, ähm Kreislaufwirtschaft, schwer herstellbar.
Waldflächen.
Wenig Waldflächen, Mono, Monokultur, großes Thema, wie gesagt, wie zum Insektenbefehl, das ist wirklich,
man lädt förmlich ein, ja? Also wirklich so ein sich so ein Super-Back zu ziehen irgendwie, ja ja.
Vieles von dem habe ich jetzt so gehört in dem in der in der Gänze, wenn man das sozusagen so hinstellt.
Müsse es ja eigentlich einem auch recht klar werden so
okay, das ist so nicht sustainable. Das ist sozusagen, das kann nicht langfristig funktionieren. Das mag kurzfristig noch nicht so messbar sein, aber viele dieser Auswirkungen, die du jetzt gesagt hast, sind ja nicht.
Sachen, die so theoretisch vielleicht irgendwann mal passieren können, sondern die finden ja alle,
mehr oder weniger gerade äh statt. So Erosion ist ein Problem, was ja auch schon gesagt sind mit dem Staub und so. Das ist richtig krass. Ähm hast du das Gefühl, dass das.
Schon verstanden wurde, dass wir da ein Problem haben.
Also,
wahrscheinlich nicht, sonst hätten wir es wahrscheinlich nicht mehr. Äh.
Also man muss ja erstmal verstehen bis man dann auch Änderungen bekommt. Ich sage mal so Klimadebatte würde ich sagen da haben wir jetzt schon kollektiv irgendwie verstanden, dass so ist. Nur.
Das dann auch zu ändern, ist dann nochmal der der nächste Schritt, aber da setzt ja sozusagen schon so eine gewisse grundsätzliche ähm Gedankenumkehr
ein. Ich will das nicht nicht sagen, es ist schon alles gut so, davon sind wir glaube ich weit entfernt, aber das ist ja absehbar. Das ist, sagen wir mal, ein großes Thema geworden.
Die Agrarwirtschaft betrifft und den Zustand der Böden und vielleicht auch so diese,
Tiefe von anstehenden Verteilungskämpfen, die das ja dann letzten Endes äh auch nach sich zieht. Das haben wir auch noch den Krieg da in der Ukraine, wo ja überhaupt sehr viel landwirtschaftliches Gut daherkommt. Das ist äh spielt ja alles da mit rein.
Das müsste sozusagen auch erstmal äh langsam reifen, diese.
Blick da drauf, weil derzeit wird ja noch Landwirtschaft verklärt als naturnah und was Leben auf dem Land ist ja so schön und ich werde Bauer und.
Auch super interessant hier, aber neue Häuser hast du jetzt viel so an Feldrändern und so und dann kommt der lokale Bauer, der hat mir wirklich das Thema haben wir hier im Dorf, ne? Kommt der lokale Bauernspritzt, der da halt nur Sando direkt an das Sound
ne, also ist halt äh lebst aufeinander, es ist giftiger als wenn du in der Stadt wohnst, ne. Also ist halt echt krass. Ähm ne eben die Kappe auch ähm ich habe,
sehr viele mittlerweile, sehr viele Menschen, die hier in der Gegend äh so die Landwirte sind. Unter anderem auch
meinen Lieblingsfreund ähm der Besitzer des Büffelhofs Pokales, der ist bekannt für den wunderbaren Büffel-Mozzarella. Musste ich jetzt mal hier so als Dings droppen. Äh unheimlich intelligenter Mann, der sehr
weitgehend denkt, ist ein Biohof, ähm und der kennt das schon, der sieht schon, ne, also das geht jetzt hier bei Mini uff.
Ja, also irgendwie, was hatten wir jetzt letztens? Wir hatten jetzt noch letzte Woche diese Woche nicht geregnet hat, also ich glaube, nächste Woche hätte er hätte er seinen ganzen Frühjahrscrub hätte er halt wegschmeißen können, but,
Essen ist für seine Rinder. Immerhin macht er selber auch das Essen für seine Rinder äh auf sein Feld an die meisten nicht mehr machen. Ähm.
Glück gehabt. Ich bin gerade als Regengott unterwegs überall, wo ich hinfahre, fängt's an zu regnen. Jetzt äh sitzen wir hier auch, wobei zumindest mit einem leichten Nieselregen
und um das vielleicht gleich mal zu lokalisieren für die Leute, die sich jetzt wundern, wo wir sind. Wir sind hier so im Süden Berlins, so also Brandenburger ähm,
Wie nennt man denn hier die Gegend.
Niedere Fläming.
Niedere Fläming, okay das das ist sozusagen der Ort, aber so geologisch äh.
Ist in niederes Fläming. Es ist geologisch der niedere Fläming und der den hohen Fläming in der niederen Flämming.
Der letzte Sander der letzten Eiszeit, auf dem wir hier sitzen grade.
Der letzte Sander, also das ist da, wo die Eiszeit angehalten hat und dann,
ist und dann gibt's dann da immer so einen Sandhügel und auf dem sitzen.
Vierzig Meter Kiessandgemisch ähm ja ähm und ja also.
Er sieht das schon und äh er sieht jetzt auch, ne, ist jetzt explodieren mir halt auch noch so die die die,
Öl und Gaspreise. Er muss für seinen Käseherstellung brauch er viel Gas, um um wirklich Hitze zu erzeugen. Ähm.
Aber er ändert nichts.
Ne, also da ist er macht stur weiter sein, wat jetzt für immer schon immer funktioniert hat. Also er stand kurz jetzt auch bei Corona da nicht viel Absatz gehabt, stand auch kurz vor einer Notschlachtung von ein paar Rindern, weil einfach sich das nicht mehr ertragen hat und so. Aber
so rein an seinem wie er das tut, erinnert er nichts. Warum ändert er nichts? Na ja es ist glaube ich systemisch. Also Kapitalismus ne
Da müsste man anfangen, den Kapitalismus in Frage zu stellen, was natürlich bei Menschen, die ein funktionierendes Business haben, was auch
gut funktioniert, also bei ihm lief das jahrelang sehr, sehr gut, würde ich sagen. Ähm muss erstmal ankommen, dass das ganze System schwächelt. So, ne ähm und dit ähm,
sinkt noch nicht ein. Äh so schlimm ist es auch noch nicht. Fragst du aber ein Pharma in Indien, der so ein versalzenes Feld hat, sieht das vielleicht schon anders aus. Also gerade in Indien ist Permakultur gerade wirklich in so einem,
abzwingen, ähm weil doch viele Lösungen gibt. Also nicht nicht für die Versalzenfelder, die sind wirklich für immer.
Also man kann die wieder auswaschen mit ganz viel Wasser. Jetzt einfach nicht mehr. Die sind halt wirklich für immer verschwunden.
Sorgt für Wälder.
Ähm ja aber da drauf wachsen halt auch keine Wälder mehr, ne. Also ja für Wälder rundrum, ja, genau, drumrum.
Wendeklima nicht schon so kaputt ist mittlerweile, dass äh auch das nicht mehr funktioniert, ne. Aber ja, Wälder ist schon,
nicht nur für CO2-Speicherung ähm wichtig. Erstmal muss man auch noch mal kurz dazu sagen, Landwirtschaft ähm oha.
Man haut mich bestimmt wieder. Ich glaube, es sind 15 Prozent für äh CHCO2 Ausstoß verantwortlich. Das ist eine sehr hohe Zahl auf jeden Fall.
Googelt das lieber nochmal anders, aber äh ist ein ist ein riesenhohe Zahl ähm äh CO2-Ausstoß, ja, Traktoren, die fahren halt den ganzen Tag hin und her. Ähm dann halt auch Methan ganz schlimm in der Tier in der Tierwirtschaft ähm
Kühe pupsen halt dann schön ähm Methan noch größere Probleme als denke ich als CO2. Ähm.
Erste, was ich finde, ist irgendwas von 7 , sechs bis zehn Prozent.
Ja, also zehn Prozent, haben wir zehn Prozent. Aber ist halt schon, ne, also wenn man Verkehr dagegen sieht und so das Große dein Sparpotenzial.
Hast du hier deinen.
Eigenen Ort gebaut, so Prototopia, ähm wie gesagt, schön im Wald äh gelegen, so mit dem Ziel.
Hier die Ideen der Permakultur konkret umzusetzen.
Einerseits, um für dich irgendwie so ein sustainable Modell äh zu bauen, aber andererseits natürlich auch, um sozusagen immer das Gefühl zu haben, das Richtige zu tun, würde ich mal sagen. Das machen wir ja alle sehr gerne.
Ja. Eine Sache, die da in der Aufzählung noch kurz fehlt, äh um auch zu gucken, ob's funktioniert.
Ja, also kann natürlich zu diesen Design-Kursen gehen und mir das alles reinpfeifen und dann funktioniert das alles. Nee, ich bin das ein Problem in der Permakultur, das viel.
Viele Leute dort unterwegs sind, die es selber nicht umsetzen, sondern das ist immer das gehört haben und auch theoretisches Wissen ohne Ende haben, aber nicht wirklich vor Ort sind und wirklich im größeren Stil auch mal,
gucken, was funktioniert denn hier von diesen ganzen Sachen, die wir hier so verbreiten
das ist äh soll wirklich auch ein Demonstrationsprojekt sein, zu zeigen, okay funktioniert das nicht.
Machst du das jetzt hier schon.
Gehen wir noch mal so ein bisschen in die Ideen rein, die jetzt durch diese Permakultur auch äh postuliert werden. Das ist ja.
Soll ich sagen? Also es gibt da so Bücher, die dann wahrscheinlich so diesen Bibel äh Charakter innerhalb dieser Szene haben und äh viel drumrum.
Was sind denn so die die Ideen? Was sind denn so die die die Grundlagen auf dem das Ganze fußt? Wo wo wird der angefangen?
Also ganz grundsätzlich haben wir erstmal eine Ethik und das äh setzt das schon mal janz janz weit.
Ab von vielen anderen Dingen, weil nichts unser gesamtes Handeln muss unterhalb dieser Ethik passieren, ansonsten ist es nicht Permakultur Punkt. Ähm.
Die Ethik hat halt, also wir haben halt also drei Ethiken, drei Punkte in dieser Ethik. Ähm das ist einmal,
mache jetzt mal die englischen, weil die deutschen Übersetzungen hänge sie gleich noch an, aber äh sie sind nicht so schön. Ist einmal erstmal ähm und fair share.
Also achtsamer Umgang mit der Erde,
Und zwar in dieser Reihenfolge. So wie Laws of Robotic, ja? Muss die Reihenfolge noch eingehalten werden. Also achtsamer Umgang mit der Erde, achtsamer Umgang mit den Menschen und Versteher kennt man so von Creative Comments heute einer.
Deine Listen nah vor allen Dingen, also wirklich ein eine gerechte Verteilung des Überschusses. Ja ähm.
Und ähm es ist wie gesagt zuerst kümmern wir uns jetzt die Erde,
und ähm sind mit der gehen mit der achtsam um. Ähm.
Weil ohne die können wir nicht existieren, ja. Ähm die produziert unser Essen äh und unser Wasser und ohne Wasser und Essen,
wir halt nichts. Da kann man jetzt sagen, okay, Nährlösungen und so weiter, irgendwie Salate anbauen und so, aber.
Wird nicht.
Also es steht quasi an Platz eins. Ich deute das mal so als egal, was wir tun, es muss erstmal gesichert werden, dass sozusagen dieser normale natürliche Zyklus der Erde selbst erhalten bleibt.
Genau. Ja, genau und äh dann das Zweite ist, egal was wir tun
Miteinander das tun und nicht gegeneinander. Also sprich wir müssen für unsere Mitmenschen sorgen
ne äh unheimlich wichtiger Punkt auch gerade in der heutigen Zeit ja ähm weil wir sehen gerade wenn so ein Krieg ist, ist halt schlecht mit Earth Care
Ja ähm.
Und will People Care auch.
People Care, dann eher durch diese nicht vorhandene People Care können wir auch keine Earth Care und auch kein Fair Share, wenn man gar keinen Überschuss mehr produzieren. Ja, also piep äh people care, also wirklich achtsamer Umgang miteinander.
Extrem essentiell. Kommen wir später dazu, dass Permacoot auf verschiedene Phasen durchgemacht hat und äh diese Phasen Mensch,
kam jetzt erst so auch erst so in den Neunzigern auf, dass die doch noch viel wichtiger ist, als man sie ursprünglich dort äh in einem Permakultur Manuel auch noch drinnen hat.
Aber die diese drei Ethikgrundlagen waren eigentlich von Anfang an da.
Ja, die waren von Anfang an da und hat es auch.
Im Kopf gehabt. Äh ich meine, es gibt dieses berühmte Chapter zwölf im ähm Permakultur-Menüal, wo er halt auf.
Auf diese wie wie funktionieren Gemeinschaften, wie funktionieren Menschen zusammen und so weiter, wie er darauf eingeht.
Ähm und das wurde halt sehr lange übersehen dieses
auch in den auch in den Kursen äh wurde wurde dann lange Zeit nicht drauf eingegangen. Später hat man rausgefunden, oh das ist mega wichtig,
Ähm und es ist sehr rudimentär dort noch. Das wurde äh gerade hier in Deutschland die Permakultur in Deutschland ist eine sehr soziale Permakultur. Da wurde sehr viel Wert drauf,
ähm in der deutschen Ausbildung ähm ist glaube ich weltweit nicht so weit wie hier in Deutschland, was was soziale Permakultur angeht. Äh durchaus so was wie Ödolf sieben Linden und äh,
und so weiter, die ähm die so was ähm mitentwickelt haben, also auch die Möglichkeiten wie in Gemeinschaften funktionieren und wie man so was aufbaut auch.
Hier in Bad Belzig. Das hat so ein bisschen eine schwierige Geschichte hinter sich mit so einem Guru, der,
haben soll, aber die haben sich dann irgendwann von Demi trennt und äh und die sitzen sitzen in einem alten.
Im alten ähm ja äh Stasiknast äh,
in Bad Belzig äh und so freie Liebe,
unter freier Liebe kennt man nit, äh die machen da so ganz viel freie Liebe, keine Ahnung. Ähm,
müsst man noch halten, was man will. Äh passt jetzt erstmal so grob erstmal nicht zu Karmakultur, aber sie haben sehr viele äh Tools entwickelt, wie Gemeinschaft funktioniert und äh da bin ich auch sehr froh, dass sich das getan haben. Also
Permakultur Cloud ganz gerne auch aus verschiedenen Ecken und Enden so das Beste heraus und die haben ähm wirklich darf da in der Richtung sehr viel.
Sehr viel geleistet. Ja ähm ja und hat auch ähm viel Übel dieser Welt. Liegt halt daran, dass äh.
Sein Reichtum nicht die Reihe gerecht verteilt ist, ja und der Reichtum in der Permakultur ist halt Essen. Ähm.
Was äh sauberes Wasser essen. Ähm.
Ein Umfeld, wo sich lohnt, zu leben. Äh und das zu teilen äh nicht nur mit anderen Menschen, muss man dazu sagen, sondern auch mit der Natur
Also generiere ich etwas,
im Überschuss ähm weiß ich jetzt nicht an andere Menschen verteilen kann ähm gebe ich das Trink der Natur zurück oder gebe jetzt dringend der Natur. Ähm,
und äh auch manchmal ist das auch so eine Sache wie Zeit zum Beispiel, einen Vogelhaus mehr bauen, weil ich jetzt gerade noch zehn Minuten habe und hier noch ein bissel Holz rumliegt, ja. Ähm das wäre zum Beispiel so ein.
Sidesharing für Flüge, ja ähm nur so als ein klingendes Beispiel am Rande, also
wissen die Ethiken. Wie gesagt, es ist ähm wenn man die so verinnerlicht hat und ich finde diesen für alle Menschen nicht nur Permakulturmenschen so gut zu verinnerlichen, sollte man vielleicht generell von Leben äh,
Immer noch toll, wenn du mal eine Partei, die so ganz oben hätte, so, ne? Das würde unser politisches System auch stark ändern.
Aber es ist zumindest ethisch geprägt, so dass es äh meine.
Kann man schon vermuten, aber es ist halt jetzt auch nicht ein rein
technokratischer Ansatz, sage ich mal, ja, mit so ja du willst ordentlich Landwirtschaft machen, hier ist irgendwie das Handbuch, da musst du's machen, sondern das Ganze ist quasi von bestimmten Leitlinien getragen, die.
Am Ende ja auch das Ziel vorgeben, was was will man eigentlich letzten Endes erreichen.
Da gibt's dann auch noch die Prinzipien. Äh wo dann mehrere Prinzipiensets gibt. Ähm.
Also mit Prinzipien ist jetzt gemeint, wie wie setzt man's konkret um oder oder was sind sozusagen die.
Also äh die die Prinzipien dienen eigentlich als für zwei Dinge. Einmal äh dienen sie als Inspiration für eine Umsetzung ähm kommen gleich drauf wie so ein Designprozess. Können wir gleich kurz souverän ähm aber einmal.
Sie als äh Inspiration und einmal als Gegencheck. Also was wenn was ich da umsetzen möchte funktioniert das? Also,
kann ich da ein paar Haken da an diesen Prinzipiensets machen, wenn ich da ganz viele Haken mache, ist das relativ wahrscheinlich, dass das auch ganz gut funktionieren wird so, ja.
Auch so ein Testsystem.
Ein Testsystem hier ja ein Testsystem ähm da gibt's äh ja gibt's die die ähm.
Die Prinzipien also von hat ein Prinzipienset äh David Homkin hat ein eigenes
David Home Prinzipien Set ist das, was eigentlich man janz oft findet, weil man ein paar Mal Kultur googelt und so. Ist so ein bisschen einfacher verständlich und nicht ganz so
nicht ganz so philosophisch, ja äh,
Äh also versteht man, versteht man schon sehr gut, weil man nur die Überschriften liest, wie zum Beispiel Beobachter und interagieren, ne, das heißt also, man setzt sich in die Natur, guckt, was passiert da überhaupt ähm und dann was kann ich drehen hier, minimal.
Ändern, um wirklich maximal was Positive zu zu erreichen, ja. Ähm,
kleine und langsame Lösung, etwas, was sich ganz schwer äh
selber verinnerlichen müsste äh für mich möchte ich ja anfangen und hier gleich mit einem Bagger über die
Landschaft fahren, aber ist überhaupt nicht gut. Manchmal Meißen macht man da Fehler und das sind dann auch so größere Fehler, die man ganz schwer wieder rückgängig machen kann, ohne noch mehr kaputt zu machen.
Und ähm ja anstatt dessen macht man so Nuklear.
Pflanzt irgendwo ein Baum und von da aus pflanzt man um den Baum pflanzen und von da aus,
man, wie breiten die sich aus? Guckt beobachtet immer wieder, ähm wie das immer wieder beobachten und da geht man wieder, guckt, welche Pflanzen funktionieren jetzt da davon, pflanzt man vielleicht mehr und dann breitet sich das aus und diese kleine Lösung, wozu man immer größeren Lösungen aber auf einer natürlichen Art und Weise ist sieht,
natürlich gewachsen. Ja.
Wachstum nennt man.
Genau. Ähm.
Wahrsten Sinne des Wortes.
Genau also oh wichtig jetzt auch in einer permakultur drei Punkt null ist ähm wichtig äh dieses dieses Prinzip vom Muster zum Detail.
Eine Sache, die muss ich hart lernen, äh hat mir so eine Lieblingsecke, ne, im Grundstück und dann fängt man da an, ne. Irgendwie ganz kleine Pflanzchen zu pflanzen und äh äh wirklich diese.
Tod zu designen, diese zwei Quadratmeter hier in den vier Hektarn ich hier habe ähm wichtiger ist es halt immer den oberen Blick zu behalten und zu
wie ist das Gesamtsystem, wie funktioniert das Gesamtsystem, wie interagieren die einzelnen Elemente in dem Gesamtsystem und ähm und und,
dann kann man immer noch ins Detail.
Gehen an bestimmten Stellen, äh aber wenn man diesen Gesamtüberblick nicht hat und auch diesen Überblick eigentlich designt mittlerweile sind wir jetzt soweit, dass er nur noch diesen Überblick designen. Also diese Details fühlen sich selber.
Die Details fühlen sich im Tun, sagen wir dann immer, also dann wenn du was machst, fühlen sich die Details, ähm aber wir designen eigentlich nur noch diesen groben Überblick äh und die wo die Verbindungen der einzelnen,
Flächen und der einzelnen Elemente verstufen.
Um's vielleicht gleich mal vor äh vorwegzunehmen, wenn du sagst design, dann ist das quasi für dich der konkrete Umsetzungsprozess dieser Permakultur Ideen auf deinen Ort.
Also genau, nicht nur mein Wort, sondern um.
Ja ja, aber in dem Fall halt, wenn du's machst auf deinem Ort.
Genau ähm,
Wir haben Designprozesse verschiedener Art zu äh viele kommen halt auch so aus dem Managementbereich tatsächlich wurden da auch
ähm grundsätzlich ist es meistens eine Beobachtung äh eine Analyse, eine Design und,
und danach gucken wir ob das Design funktioniert. Also ein Feedback.
Also das kann man schon, das ist meistens. Wie man wie man diese einzelnen Teile strukturiert, da gibt's ganz viele Unterschiede. Arbeitet es im Prinzip zu,
Design machen. Gibt's denn auch noch Funky Designs ähm mit irgendwie Dragon Dreaming, wo man in einer Gruppe sitzt und äh ja, das hört sich hier super esoterisch an, ist aber supermächtig äh ein ein Design-Tool für Gruppen,
Also ist wirklich so, um äh mit Gruppen ein Projekt zu gestalten, das Dragon Dreaming extrem cool. Hört sich scheiße an, ich.
Dragon Dreaming.
Dreaming, ja, muss man mal googeln, das äh kommt auch aus diesem Manager, wirklich so keine Ahnung, zu managen, Manager schulen, ich weiß nicht genau, wo es herkommt, aber es ist äh äh ja, es ist spannende System.
Aber bleiben wir doch noch mal erstmal, bevor wir auf diese konkrete Umsetzung äh kommen, so auf diese diese Prinzipien. Vielleicht kannst du ja nochmal so zwei, drei herausgreifen, die in irgendeiner Form gut charakterisieren
wie hier eigentlich die die Denklogik
äh ist, weil mir erscheint das ja eben alles sehr prozessual zu sein. Abgeleitet von einer Ethik auf sozusagen
Vorgehensweisen, so würde ich das vielleicht mal nennen, das grade als Prinzipien. Prinzipien klingt ja so mit, oh muss das sein und.
Darf ich dich abweichen, aber ich verstehe es eigentlich mehr so als äh so Verhaltensmuster äh äh an denen man sich orientieren kann, um einen Ansatz zu finden
später dann eben für eine konkrete Umsetzung dieser Ideen. Kann man das so.
Das kann man genau so sagen. So würde ich das jetzt auch sagen. Mein Muster ist noch ein anderes Thema, eine Permakultur, wo wir ein Muster, was die Natur für Muster macht und äh weiter, aber ähm.
Okay, aber sozusagen jetzt hier ein Muster der Vorgehensweise.
Muster der Vorgehensweise, genau. Ähm finde ja die, weil sie sind wieder ein bisschen mehr
aber äh so das Problem ist die Lösung äh so ein ein Prinzip von finde das ein unheimlich mächtiges äh Prinzip ja. Wir gucken äh wat.
Uns dieses Problem dann überhaupt ähm so und äh wir hatten hier zum Beispiel aufm Grundstück ähm unheimliches Problem mit Wühlmäusen. Ja, das Problem.
Blühmäuse, ja, also voll das ist ja ähm wir haben die Salate einfach unten weggezogen und so weiter. Ähm und äh.
Fängst du an wo willst du die bekämpfen? Ah nicht anders sein Gift kommt sowieso nicht in Frage ne gibt's dann irgendwie Sachen kannst du explodieren bringen ist auch nicht so ernst,
so ja. Ähm so und da habe ich gesagt, okay Problem ist die Lösung. Was gibt die Natur denn hier so für das Problem für eine Lösung so und haben die machen lassen. Und es dauerte keine zwei Monate kam ein Fuchs.
Und der Fuchs kam jeden Tag und der Fuchs kam jeden Tag äh am Ende gleich noch ein bisschen da. Gefüttert, weil das war auch lieb äh nach meiner Entwurmung, weil es ist ja doof so ein Fuchsbandwurm, um einen Salat zu haben und äh der Fuchs kommt bis heute jeden Tag. Der Fuchs hat,
wir haben immer noch paar Mybeweise, aber ist auf keinen Fall mehr ein Problem. Ja, einfach ja, einfach machen lassen.
Also ihr habt einfach Geduld sozusagen.
Äh in dem Moment Geduld, genau ähm gibt äh da definitiv auch noch bessere bessere Beispiele. Aber das ist ähm.
Äh ja Randzonen ist hier auch noch eine Prinzipprinzip, da kann ich noch mal ganz spezielles Beispiel nennen.
Wir haben jetzt hier diese relativ graden so äh mittlerweile baue ich mich herausgezogen äh Müse an äh meinen Lebensunterhalt zu machen, weil ich.
Gemerkt habe, das hin und her pendeln liegt mir nicht so, habe ich keinen Bock mehr. Wenn du hier bist, möchtest du nicht mehr weg, weil's hier zu schön ist und so weiter und äh dein Gemüse.
War so diese Losthanging Fruit, also wirklich zu sagen das sieht ja relativ schnell los, da bis in einer Saison soweit.
Produkt zu haben, im Gegensatz zu Baumschulen und so weiter wurde halt länger dauert oder Software oder so, ja.
Ähm genau, dann äh haben wir ja diese richtig geraden Reihen so, weil's einfach effektiver ist, muss halt leider sein, für tausend verschiedenen Gründen. Ähm
wir haben halt so Ranzzonen an diesem Namen und diese Ranzonen sind extrem durchdesignt äh bei mir. Ähm vor allen Dingen einmal.
Gebe ich diesen äh diesen Space sozusagen mit der mit der Natur. Es ist Fair Share, wirklich mein,
mein Land hier, mein Überschuss Land, gebe ich halt zum großen Teil der Natur, also wirklich sehr wilde Zwischenstreifen.
Die äh überall wirklich sehr, sehr eng. Meine Felder sind sehr, sehr klein. Äh vierhundert, 500 Quadratmeter teilweise nur und dazwischen gibt's halt immer wirklich sehr breite, ausgefallene Streifen. Und ähm jetzt mein und,
zwischen dieser Natur, ist eine ganz krasse Natur und die sind absolut geraden Rhein. Äh machen wir jetzt nur noch äh Kräuter, vor allen Dingen Salbei.
Ähm deren Output bringt, super gut ist, äh wenn er blüht für für Schmetterlinge, ähm.
Und äh Output heißt halt, ich kann den Salbei auch ähm verkaufen und ähm er ist Unkraut unterdrückend und er sahmt sich nicht aus. Ähm ist halt so ein perfekter Randbepflanzung, ja. Die ähm.
Wo ich die Ranzzone beachtet habe. Ja, wenn man jetzt so unter normal fällt, geht das A die Randzone, da wo der Traktor umwendet.
Ja hin und wieder hat man mal noch so einen Streifen dazwischen, aber selten und mittlerweile müssen sie glaube ich wieder, aber es sind sehr selten geworden, dieser Streifen und aber alle 100 Hekt
haben, die mal so eine Wildhecke, die dann auch mit Monsanto zugeweht wird und so weiter. Ähm oder ich designed ist, also,
Wirklich Gehölze rein, wo auch Kleinlebewesen sind, Schutz drunter finden. Ähm ich habe ganz viele Eidechsen jetzt. Ist auch spannend. Du baust so was und sofort kommt die Natur,
sofort eindechsen da gehabt, die da drinnen äh Kröten et cetera, ne, die da drin auch hausen und natürlich auch meine Insekten wieder fressen,
Ähm genau, also ranzoomen nicht außer Acht lassen, das ist auch so was. Ähm erziele einen Ertrag, ist auch immer das Ernten.
Du machst das auch um wirklich einen Ertrag zu erzielen. Wir müssen ja überleben und wir haben sind überbevölkert, ja. Am Ende des Tages geht's schon darum auch Essen zu generieren für uns. Ähm plustet halt dann irgendwie in dem Einklang und irgendwie nachhaltig und in einer Kreislaufwirtschaft möglich,
Ähm äh genau. Ja
ist auch einfach zu verstehen, Ertrag mache ich hier das Gemüse, das ist mein Ertrag. Dafür habe ich jetzt hier auch noch Wildzeug, wo Kindertag passiert, aber eigentlich überall Ertrag. Und Jens von Molissens äh Prinzipien ist noch ähm
Es gibt ähm kein Limit im System, was den Ertrag angeht. Ich weiß nicht genau, wie genau heißt aber so im im Dings. Und dit ist sehr, sehr spannend,
das haben wir hier mal durchexerziert. Ähm du kannst äh.
Immer wieder noch wat druff schmeißen, hast immer mehr Ertrag äh äh ne also im Endeffekt möchte ich hier aus dem Wald.
Der Wald soll niederwald werden. Das ist so eine Waldkultur, wo man Bäume abschneidet, die wachsen dann wieder aus ihrem,
Stöcken wieder aus, treiben wieder aus. Das kann man alle 12 bis 30 Jahre machen. Daraus werden Hackschnitzel, die Hackschnitzel werden's pilzen. Die Pilze wären.
Äh aber das was übrig bleibt wird so Kompass der Kompost wird zu äh Gemüse Gemüse.
Boden auf, wenn man einmal geilen Kompost machte, braucht er nicht allen Nährstoffe, da kann man wieder Wald machen, hat man Kreislaufwirtschaft, aber in dem Wald
gibt's natürlich dann auch noch Bäume pflanzen. Jetzt da Bäume, die essen abwerfen, ne ähm zum Beispiel Esskastanien, supergeiler Baum, der viel Essen abwirft.
Hast du zwar den Baum, den äh schneidest einen Pilze und Gemüse machst, aber hast du halt auch noch Esskastanien dazu. Und das kannst du halt weiter skalieren und skalieren, ne. Also der Baum
bietet Schatten, macht Wasser, ähm
Ne, also diese da das ist wirklich so ein System, kein Uplimit hat. Du kannst eigentlich richtig System immer weiter äh Zeit ist dann ein Limit, vereid mal, ne und äh und Wille auch, wie weit willst du denn da auch gehen? Ähm
fällt leider jetzt letztens noch ein besseres Beispiel, fällt mir jetzt gerade leider nicht ein, aber.
Ein Gedanke zwischendurch, der mir jetzt gerade äh kam, weil ich versuche gerade für mich selber auch immer so ein bisschen eine Definition zu finden oder eine weitere Definition zu finden, was
quasi so mit dieser was der Ansatz der Permakultur äh ist und es offensichtliche äh ist ja klar, ne ja irgendwie nachhaltig et cetera, nur die Art und Weise wie man
darauf jetzt hinzielt auf welche Art und Weise man hier nachhaltig ist und ich habe so ein bisschen das Gefühl, es ist so.
Man versucht eigentlich im Wesentlichen die Natur so wie sie sich wild entwickeln würde, weit,
Kind so zu behalten wie sie eben von alleine läuft nur man.
Leitet sie in bestimmten Stellen einfach in einen in einen von mehreren.
Normalerweise frisch ausgewürfelten Pfade und sagt so, ja, nimm mal lieber das, wie du das jetzt zum Beispiel meinst, mit dieser hätte ja auch irgendwas anderes wachsen können, was eben jetzt
kein äh Nahrung, unmittelbar äh abwirft, aber ökologisch in dem Moment natürlich genauso gut funktioniert hätte und greift sozusagen an den Stellen ein
unterlässt es aber eben auch ganz bewusst an anderen äh Stellen einzugreifen, einfach um an der Stelle den Benefit eben der natürlichen Diversität zu haben. Die
zu haben, die Vögel zu haben, die Würmer zu haben, die die Tiere äh und die ganzen sonstigen Anführungsstrichen Abfallprodukte ähm
die gemeinhin dann unter solchen Begriffen wie Unkraut
so, ja, da wächst jetzt das, was ich ja eigentlich haben will, ja ist ja nicht der Weizen, ist ja nicht äh was auch immer für ein Gemüse ich jetzt hier haben will. Alles, was da nicht wächst, ist quasi der Feind. Und,
Scheint diese Permakultur einfach umzuinterpretieren und zu sagen so ist erstmal überhaupt äh kaum,
jemals ein ein Feind da. Es kann natürlich sein, dass äh etwas,
zu viel vorkommt wie deine Wühlmäuse, ja ähm die äh in dem Moment stören, weil ich würde ja gerne hier diese lokale Balance mehr in Richtung Ertrag drücken.
Ne, damit ich daraus eben quasi wirklich auch eine eine Ernährung oder im Idealfall ja auch,
wirtschaftlichen Betrieb draus äh machen kann. Aber man treibt es halt nie so so weit, dass man eben nur diesen Ertrag sieht, sondern dass man sozusagen immer das das gesamte Ökosystem im Wesentlichen äh
laufen lässt und so ein bisschen wie so ein DJ eigentlich äh versucht äh einfach äh Schwerpunkte zu setzen.
Ja, also.
Ist mir normal. Jetzt muss ich nochmal ganz kurz die gleich drauf ein. Immer ganz kurz, weil ähm das Problem ist, die Lösung hatte keine so gutes Beispiel, aber Beispiel, wo sich jeder mit wahrscheinlich äh identifizieren kann. Das ist immer hat so ein Brennnessel, so eine Ecke, wo nur Brennnessel wächst und,
ja und das ist ein Problem. Er möchte weg haben, ja möchte man irgendwie was Schönes haben und so
essbar ähm Restaurants mittlerweile neben Brennnessel lieben gerne ab, weil es wirklich ein Kultgemüse irgendwie in der Restaurants geworden. Ähm ich habe leider überhaupt keine Bremse mehr, aber mein Restaurant. Ich wollte echt
und ich dachte so, ey das wäre natürlich eine wunderschöne Lösung für ein Problem, wäre am Ende jetzt hier wirklich so eine Ecke brennen hätte, ne? Aber das ist so ein klassisches
Problem und so. Nur dit noch mal am Rande, weil's mir gerade eingefallen ist als Handgreifding, also hast halt ja das Problem, ist die Lösung. Ähm,
Genau. Äh ansonsten ja, also mit dem DJ. Ähm das äh.
Sozusagen so ein Natur-DJ geworden.
Im Idealfall wäre im Idealfall verwertet und ähm wir wollen das kam auch aus dieser Ecke, der hat viel mit indigenen auch gearbeitet, auch in Afrika, war sehr lang in Afrika, hat äh war nicht dort,
muss man ihm wirklich zuhalten. Er ist nicht der typische weise, alte weise Mann, der da sagt, du müsstet so und so machen, sondern er hat zugehört. Hat auch immer die indigenen Frauen ganz.
Auch in jedem seiner Speeches hat er die wirklich ganz weit oben gesagt,
die in die gehen Frauen oder in äh Frauen wirklich, die noch die noch Originale, auch Originale Landwirtschaft betreiben. Also wir haben meist Wissen auf der Welt, um diese Welt zu retten. Äh es war immer sein von Anfang an sein äh sein Basel. Ähm.
Sprich äh gibt jetzt da halt auch ähm
wunderbare Studien auch äh die die indigenen Völker in ähm in Kalifornien, die dort äh sehr friedliebend miteinander über Jahrtausenden gelebt haben, bis der weiße Mann kam. Ähm dort genau das getan haben. Die waren DJs, der Natur, die haben kein klassischen Ackerbau betrieben. Äh sie haben aber auch nicht,
nichts gemacht und haben nur gesammelt, sondern sie haben durch ihre Einwirkung auf die Natur, die stark durch Beobachtungen äh mit,
durch Beobachtungen geprägt waren, ähm unheimlich das gesamte Landschaft dort verändert. Diese ersten Berichte wie toll Kalifornien einfach ein Paradies ist mit tausenden Blüten und so weiter ähm sind darauf zurückführen, dass
wirklich die gesamte Landschaft geändert haben und zwar zu einer essbaren Landschaft, die für sie,
einem minimalen Input und man redet hier von zwei Monaten im Jahr pro Person, haben sie dafür gebraucht, um ihr gesamtes Essen für euren gesamten Nährstoffe fürs ganze Jahr,
zu generieren.
Also super effizient auch.
Effizient. Ja und die waren dann auch friedlich. Die hatten von allen genug, deswegen haben die sich untereinander dort äh nicht bekriegt, also mal so.
Weil es keine Verteilungskämpfe gab.
Eine Verteilungskämpfe und sie hatten Zeit. Das sieht man halt auch an dieser ganzen äh Technik, wie sie Körbe flechten und so. Das ist unheimlich zeitintensiv und.
Verschossen muss muss man nicht so äh wahnsinnig toll machen, aber es ist einfach, die hatten einfach Zeit dafür, ja? Die hatten einfach Bock drauf, dann haben die halt ein bisschen Kunst gemacht in Form von wem, was sie noch für Kunst gemacht haben, willst man kaum, weil,
die hatten keine.
Und in diesen zwei Monaten im Jahr haben sie sich sozusagen darauf konzentriert äh,
der Natur an der richtigen Stelle Schubs zu geben. So nach dem Motto, okay, du könntest dich jetzt so oder so entscheiden, entscheide dich mal so, ich greife jetzt hier mal ein, aber nicht durch Zerstörung, Entfernung, Vernichtung, sondern eben durch,
kluge Maßnahmen, die dann in die richtige Richtung führen.
Feuer auch, ja, muss man schon mal sagen, also die haben ja schon mal auch aber auch wichtig, wie man jetzt sieht in California, großen Waldbrände. Liegt auch da dran, dass,
kleinen Feuer, die regelmäßig passiert sind, nicht mehr passieren, sondern das ist jetzt richtig Feuer Material da, was
nicht weggenommen wird alle zwei Jahre, sondern er hat alle 30 Jahre so ein ganzer Wald abbrennt, weil das ein bisschen hoch in die Kronen geht, ja. Ähm aber halt auch mit so einem Stock
durch die Gegend und da irgendwelche äh Knollen ausgegraben und dadurch die Herde ein bisschen locker gemacht und dann sind dann bessere Knollen gewachsen, weil durch diese durch diese einfachen Akt
dieses mit dem Stock.
Äh hochmachen und einzelne Knollen hier und da rausnehmen. Konnten die sich besser verbreiten, gab's dann irgendwie Lilien, Felder, alles voller Lilien, wunderschön, ne? Also kann man sich nur vorstellen, dass wenn da so ein weißer Mann kommt und alles voller Livien ist, ne aber
war die Knollenwand für die Essen sozusagen, ne.
Oder halt Risome ausgegraben von irgendwelchen Grassenflechten und so und dadurch auch den Boden wieder ein bisschen die Resomen, die dann danach wachsen, grade gewachsen. Und die zwei Monate natürlich nicht am Stück, sondern übers Jahr
verteilt, ne. Das muss man auch dazu sagen. Das ist so das eine, äh dann ist aber äh in der in der idealen Welt ja einfach gerne nur der der Diss-Jockey, der hier sagt, okay, da so ein bisschen dit und dann pflanze ich mal da einen Baum und so, aber äh Kapitalismus und
auch unsere Ernährung, ja? Wir müssten halt also um das,
funktioniert. Das müssten wir in den 90 Prozent Ernährungsumstellung machen. Also müssten alle alle Grains rauswerfen, also alles, was Weizen, Mais und so weiter aus der Ernährung rausscheint.
Unbedingt möglich. Ja und das ist wahrscheinlich auch, wo wir herkommen und was auch viel viel gesünder für uns ist, ja. Zurückgehen zu Eiche, äh Esskastanie.
Nüssen. Ja also diese also diese drei also alle Nüsse,
Weiche und Erskastanie, also diese drei Dinge können halt komplett sämtlich äh unsere also unsere Bulk halt ersetzen, also Weizenmais.
Ja. Eicheln, Eskaltan, Escastanien.
Und Nüsse und Haselnüsse, Walnüsse, also hier in unserer Gegend, Was sind das, Walnüsse, Pekanüsse, et cetera äh Nüssen super viel Öl auch, so Ölproblem, Raps gelöst, ne äh viel mehr Öl, ne.
Baut man nicht an, ist schwierig zu ernten im großen Maß.
Man auch dazu sagen. Das ist der Grund, warum wir keine Haselnussfelder haben. Ja, Haselnuss, grandiose Gewächs, vielleicht braucht nix, wächst hier hinten bei mir in meiner Wüste hier mitten im Wald und da im Schatten,
Also ist wirklich das braucht einfach nix. Äh ein Riesenertrag, wenn du wirklich ich ne, aber ernte mal so einen Haselnuss, ne? Also gibt's da schon voll Ernte und so, aber die machen da auch viel Köpfe von den Büschen kaputt, das ist noch nie aus, nicht ausgereift. Damit auch nicht,
ja, nicht sehr nicht sehr lukrativ sage ich mal. Äh aber im Prinzip ähm,
Hat man ausgerechnet, äh dass wir ein ein Zehntel der Anbauflächen für den gleichen.
In der Nichtöl, also alles, also äh für die gleichen Kalorienertrag, vor allen Dingen erstmal. Öl ist nochmal ganz eigenes Ding, weil,
nach Ölen, genau. Äh überall in aller Munde ist so, also die produzieren auch noch Öl zusätzlich, aber so eine Haselnuss drückt das Öl aus, hast trotzdem noch total viel Kalorien,
Ja? Äh Haselnussmehl draus machen. Äh ich habe mal ein Eichenbrot gemacht gebacken, das ist ein sehr langwieriger Prozess, weil
null Automatisierung gibt, machst du alte Hand im Moment so, ne? Aber ist möglich, ja? Hat man auch gezeigt nachher in der Walnuss kannst du auch mittlerweile maschinell knacken. Ähm aber wenn da so ein Eichenbrot isst, isst du halt,
ein Viertel davon und bist so pubert, da sind viertel Brot und du bist so pappsatt, dass du nicht mehr essen kannst.
Eichebrot. Brot aus Eicheln.
Genau. Ja. Kann ich sehr empfehlen. Schmeckt unheimlich gut. Großartig. Also.
Ja ich versuche mir grad nur vorzustellen, wie man das überhaupt produziert äh.
Ja, die Eicheln musst du fellen, da musst du die innere Sapellen, dann musst du das ähm wässern, ganz viel. Früher haben die das einfach in den Bach gehangen, wieder Permakultur. Super easy, ne, also unsere unsere Vorfahren einfach.
Hängst du den Scheiß in einen einen Bach, wartest ein halbes Jahr, machst nichts, hängt da einfach so, holst es raus, ist es fertig, ja? Äh.
Passiert dann mit den Eich.
Dann wird ähm der Termin wird ausgewaschen. Das ist etwas so bitter schmeckt in Eicheln. Kannste aber mit wirklich jeder Eiche der Welt machen, ja? Bei manchen dauert's länger, weil die mehr Termin haben, bei manchen weniger lange.
Und dann hast du eine Substanz, aus der du ein Brot machen.
Ja, die trockenste, nahlste, haste Mehl, kannst du Brot backen. So und Eichen, ne, also wir stellen uns hier so einen Eichenbaum vor, ne
und wie viele Eicheln da runterfallen, kannst du halt mehrere Schweine von füttern ganzes Jahr lang, von einem Eichenbaum, kannst du halt auch mehrere Menschen von Füttern ein ganzes Jahr lang wächst, so vor sich hin, musst du nüscht machen, musst du nicht jedes Jahr aufpflügen, neuen Baum pflanzen et cetera.
Ähm wenn wir,
in die Richtung umstellen, dann werden die spielen. Solange wir das nicht tun und wir hier nochmal in jährliche Gemüse, weil jeder will sein perfektes Gemüse aus dem meistens Kreuzblüter auch äh mit den tausend
Pests, die da jetzt da so auf den großen Feldern jetzt zu äh angezogen wurden. Gegen die bin ich ja auch nicht alle immun, sage ich so, wie es ist. Wenn hier der Flughäfer vom Rapsfeld kommt
ein Kilometer entfernt kann ich da nicht gegen machen. Da können auch tausend Vögel hier rumschurren. Also
kapiere dich dir, ist zehnmal höher als alles was da unten ist aber äh den Flug hier, wir kriegen die auch nicht Platz so ne und sprich da Musik schon auch noch Maßnahmen mal treffen, leider Gottes und äh
aber gleichzeitig versuche ich halt die Leute auch zu ähm unterrichten so ein bisschen, ne. Ähm zum Unkraut zu erziehen.
Gehen wir nochmal konkret auf diesen Ort äh ein Prototopia.
Das ist hier ein Waldstück kein besonders aufregender Wald, ähm würde ich jetzt mal so sagen, ne, so ein Kieferwald oder was ist hier? Ich bin ja noch nicht so.
Grundstück genommen, weil tatsächlich wesentlich aufregender ist als jetzt vielleicht zwei so gerade noch keine Blätter dran und so.
Äh aber wenn man's wenn man's auf Google Maps guckt ähm ich bin hier in einem Meer aus Kiefern Monokultur der hat einzige äh Laubwaldstück überhaupt.
Die vorgehenden Besitzer haben äh hier Apfelbäume drauf gehabt und haben die Russen hier, die in so einen Übungsplatz im Norden hatten. Da haben die Äpfel mal geklaut und dann haben die so vor 30 Jahren geschlossen.
Also erst haben sie eine Mauer um das Grundstück gebaut so eine zwei Meter mit selber gegossenen Stein. Und dann äh kamen die halt immer noch über die Mauer
gab's wohl auch einen Zwischenfall mit irgendwie Messerstecherei und so, keine Ahnung. Und dann haben die halt die ganzen Apfelbäume alle gefällt und haben Ahorn gepflanzt. So und dann ist dieser Ahorn.
Mischwald, sage ich mal, sind noch ein paar Eichen bei, ein paar Rotechen auch, äh paar Stierechen, bisschen Hopfenbuch und so, aber es ist generell ähm immerhin haben sie keine Kiefern gepflanzt, sage ich mal, ja und das ist auch sehr spannend.
Bei rundrum,
Sind nur Kiefern und Förster, der hier war, der war wurde auch überhaupt nicht mehr. Der hat gesagt, boah, gibt's hier einfach nirgendswo so ein so ein richtiger Laubmischwald so, ne. Ähm spannend auch, wir haben auch eine S-Kastanie.
Die wachsen hier nicht laut Förster, ja. Ich habe gesagt, ja ich will dann hinten meinen Wald, es gibt noch einen zweiten Teil vom Grundstück, der ist wirklich Kiefer äh kiefer Birke Mischwald ähm wir äh wahrscheinlich sogar.
Von alleine gewachsen, so wie es aussieht und keine Reihen. Und ich habe gesagt, die möchte ich gerne.
Tendenziell umwalten in äh in Esskastanie und der Faust äh der offizielle Förster kam hier. Hier wachsen keine Esskastanien und ich habe halt hier diesen mega Eskastan im Baum stehen, so der war wunderschön ist auch und ähm.
Habe ich ihm gezeigt und ja da wurde halt ja nicht ja ursprünglich gesagt eins der Gründe ist das und zweitens weil's so ein Extremstandorte.
Ähm wir sind hier auf vierzig Meter Sand in einem der trockensten Gebiete Deutschland. Ähm es ist düster,
Äh vor zwei Jahren hat sich der ganze Wald entlaubt. Also das war so trocken, dass wirklich selbst die ausgewachsenen vierzig, 50 Jahre alten Bäume kein Laub mehr drauf hatten am Ende des Jahres. Ähm also mir dann auch wirklich Tränen gerührt und nochmal gezeigt
muss hier,
wirklich also das ist wirklich wichtig, dass ich bin hier so am am an der Grenze des Klimawandels. Ähm zu angekommen, so also A sind extrem Gebiet, also wenn hier Sturm ist, ist hier richtig Sturm.
Ähm Regen meistens nicht, wenn's aber irgendwo anders regnet. Jetzt hat's gerade.
Außer außer wenn ich.
Also wenn du kommst, genau ähm,
Ja, auch in diesem Jahr, wo es so gar nicht geregnet hat, warte ich, ich habe eine Wasserstation hier, äh so eine Wundergroundwetterstation, die so in diesem größten Wetter-Netzwerk
hängt und ich war in Deutschland die Wetterstation mit dem wenigsten Regen und die ist eingemessen, die ist gut, die funktioniert.
Es gibt auch nicht nur drei davon von diesen Wetterstationen.
Ne ne, also die Deutschland richtig sticht besiedelt mit diesem Wetterstation. Äh weiß nicht wie viel, zehntausend.
Du bist der trockenste Ort.
Ich war vor zwei Jahren in diesem Jahr definitiv bei weitem der trockenste Ort. Ich hatte.
Zweihundertzehn oder so mehr oder hundertneunzig oder so. Ich weiß nicht mehr ganz genau, irgendwie sowas. Dit ist Arit.
Was?
Millimeter im Jahr. Im.
Das also wenn die Evakuation im Sommer höher ist als der Niederschlag und unter 250 Millimeter liegt,
war ich beides. Also das kann man dann ausrechnen, wie viel Sonne kommt und so weiter. Ähm Harit heißt halt Wüste.
Ne, also wir reden hier wirklich von einer Verwüstung auch tatsächlich dann in dem Moment. Äh bin sehr, sehr froh, dass es letztes Jahr dann geregnet hat. Letztes Jahr auch noch so weitergegangen,
hätte ich hier abheizen müssen. Also ich habe habe weiterhin Trockenschäden. Viele Bäume haben's nicht überlebt. Grad die Fichten natürlich, die haben's auch bei mir hier nicht, weil ich ein paar Fichten standen noch dazu,
Aber halt auch der Ahorn hat massiv.
Ja ich habe auch so ein kleines äh Gärtchen in Brandenburg, da hat's dann irgendwie letztes Jahr auch die Apfelbäume alle gekillt und nicht nicht mehr viel übrig geblieben.
Ja, det äh ja die Apfelbäume, die man auch kauft, auch ganz schwierig, weil man die da die den Haupttrieb,
abkattet, weil die Idee war da, der hat die Oberfläche hat Amelie Nährstoff, dann wächst er schneller, ja, aber an die Oberfläche hat er auch weniger Wasser, wenn's richtig trocken ist, ne? Und wenn man ihn einmal diesen
die Hauptwurzel, dann wächst ihr halt nicht nach. Ähm und dann hat man halt so feine ja feine feine Wurzeln oben.
Okay, also das war jetzt sozusagen der der Grund, warum du hierher gegangen bist hast, also hier zumindest äh so
super anspruchsvoll, also dass es jetzt trocken ist, ist ja, sagen wir mal aus landwirtschaftlicher Perspektive erstmal nicht gut, aber du hast es quasi als Herausforderung angenommen.
Ja, ja, also ich äh für mich war immer klar, also für den Grundstück kam auch um zu zeigen, was möglich ist und wenn ich da jetzt so das perfekte Grundstück habe mit irgendwie Südhagen, äh wehm ich
sannige Erde mit irgendwie einem Bach, der da durchläuft. Ähm kannst du nicht zeigen. Also machen viele so. Ja, ich habe hier ein Permakulturgrundstück und gucke, wie schön das ist. Ja.
Mach mal nix, das ist immer noch schön, ja.
Genau. Du wolltest sozusagen in der Wüste machen.
Wollten ein bisschen zeigen, dass man auch produzieren kann vor allen Dingen auch. Also auch wirklich Essen, auch wirklich ein Output bringt. Ähm,
Bin dann hier angekommen, dass es dann so schlimm wird gleich am Anfang. Hätte ich jetzt nicht gedacht, äh mir gedacht, ich habe mir Zeit. Das war wirklich meine einzige Fehleinschätzung. Ich dachte, ich habe zwanzig, 30 Jahre,
dann fängt es an, richtig, richtig einzuschlagen mit dieser Klimawandel, dass es jetzt schon so krass einschlägt
ist kein gutes Zeichen, ja also Klimawandel, wenn dann net klar mit also wirklich äh unstetiget Wetter, also wirklich Wetter, was extreme macht. Ähm eine Permakultur schon immer, kleine eher als Klimawandel, also ist wirklich,
wird einfach extremer in die sämtlichen Richtungen und.
Schwere einschätzen. Ähm als ich angefangen hatte, da ging das ja alles noch, ne. Also so sagt man so vor sieben, acht, neun, zehn Jahren äh haste mal ein bisschen wärmer und ein bisschen verarbeitet. Hat noch nicht,
war noch nicht im im vorderen Gehirn angekommen so. Äh und ich dachte, na ich kann hier alles,
machen, um Wasser zu sammeln und so weiter und dann pflanze ich da kleine Bäumchen drauf und die wachsen dann schön und dann in zwanzig, 30 Jahren habe ich kein Schönheitssystem und dann,
wie resilient es ist. Ja, Pustekuchen, äh zweite Jahr, ich hatte hier schon so Wasser,
Features eingebaut, die Wasserhalter aber das funktioniert hier auf meinem Sandboden super langsam, weil ich habe keine Oberflächenwasser.
Haut nach unten ab. Sprich kann nur durch Biomasse sammeln und Biomasse muss erstmal anfangen ein bisschen zu zersetzen, dass die Wasser auftaucht und so weiter. Und die Idee ist wirklich Bäume zu pflanzen, die da in die Biomasse reingehen und,
da das Wasser rausziehen, aber die Bäume waren halt alle. Ja und äh,
Ich habe gerade so die Biomasse dahingelegt. So und dann brennt es halt auch noch hier so um die Ecke, ne? Das kam dann auch noch dazu. Äh klar lernen wir auch in der Permakultur für Brand,
zu designen äh und zu gucken, dass man so hat, aber das war hier erstmal so nicht so,
vorher ist ein Thema und dann haben wir hier den größten Waldbrand ähm Deutschland, die je gesehen hat, nicht mal vierzig, 130 kenne ich nee, 20 Kilometer entfernt, sage ich mal, warte.
Anderen Seite der Stadt sozusagen. Also jetzt bis zur Stadt und dann auf der anderen Seite da war dann der der Waldbrand.
Glücklicherweise nicht hier auf unserer Seite. Ähm und äh ja das hat mein ganzes, diese ursprünglichste Design, was ich gemacht habe, wo ich auch noch ein bisschen naiv auch rangegangen bin teilweise, weil man fängt ja auch gerade erst an.
Komplett zerrissen und in Papierkorb getan und habe komplett nochmal neu eingefangen.
Lass uns mal auf diesen Designprozess jetzt äh kommen. Also wie bist du jetzt hier äh rangegangen, in welchem Zustand befand sich ähm das Geländer, als sie hier kamst und und was ist dann sozusagen.
Wie wie gehst du vor? Also was was ist der erste Gedanke, was muss was muss man erstmal sichern, worum geht's? Geht's erstmal um um Pflanzenauswahl, plant man erstmal seine Ernte. Das Ganze hat ja auch noch so wirtschaftliche äh äh,
pickte, wenn man davon leben will und es ist jetzt nicht nur so ein reines Hobby ist, ähm was was ist da jetzt das Erste, welche von deinen Permakulturprinzipien hast du quasi als erste äh ausge,
oder hast du mehr oder weniger alles gleichzeitig zum Einsatz gebracht uns doch mal so ein bisschen durch die Schritte durch die die da gemacht hast.
Also das erste was wir immer machen ist beobachten und,
mehr rückwirkend kann ich das nur sagen. Umso länger wir umso länger man beobachtet, umso besser. Ja? Äh ich würde sagen, wenn man wirklich ein landbasiertes Design macht unter einem Jahr beobachten, bevor man überhaupt anfängt äh,
auf keinen Fall.
Also erstmal gucken, was was wächst hier überhaupt, was ist hier überhaupt, wie verhält sich das, wie ändert sich das über das Jahr, wieviel Wasser ist hier, wie viel Schnee, was weiß ich, Wind.
Genau das. Genau das. Wind, Sekt. Wir haben da so bestimmte Tools, Sektorierung, wo kommt der Wind her? Wo kommt
kann das Feuer herkommen, ne, also so was beobachtest dann halt ja auch ähm wo es Lärm, ne, also manchmal ist so eine Straße und so weiter. Das ist eine Altbeobachtungs äh Geschichten, ja da gibt's so ein
tausend Übungen, sind Spot, suchst dir einen Ort, von dem jeden Tag früh rausgehst, dort dahin, tust nichts, beobachtest mal zehn Minuten, einfach guck,
jeden Tag. Was passiert dort? Tierweltgeräusche, Pflanzen, Vertext, wie wie fühlt sich's an, Wind, wie fühlt's sich an, wenn es regnet,
passiert mit dem Regen auf der Erde und so weiter, ne? Also das muss man jetzt nicht mit so einem Sitzspot machen, das kommt aus der Wildnispädagogik sehr schöne Tour, um wirklich zu beobachten, aber äh auch übers Gelände gehen, einfach gucken zu jeder Jahreszeit, ne, wat
wie ist der Schnee? Gibt's da Schneewihen et cetera, ne?
Schreibst du dann alles auf oder.
War dann halt auch eine extrem äh schreibt man alles uff, genau, so die wichtigsten
Erlebnisse, die man so hat, äh schon notieren. Ich war dann auch wirklich noch extrem an dieser Beobachtungsphase, habe wirklich äh dreimal am Tag
äh dreimal am Tag viermal im Jahr äh an 21 Stellen wirklich Bodentemperatur, Licht ähm Foto gemacht, ein Rundumfoto gemacht ähm wirklich äh um wirklich auch.
Ähm pH-Wert gemessen in dem Boden an der Stelle et cetera, also um zu gucken, was ändert sich da auch im Laufe des Jahres oder wo habe ich auch eine warme Stelle rausgefunden, hier sind sechs Grad Unterschied aufm Grundstück.
Empolen.
Im Boden, sechs Grad.
Sechs Grad, also von daher äh nee, das war bloß so ein Bodenthermometer in der oberen Schicht so. Ja ähm.
Also da in der Schicht, in der jetzt Gemüse anbauen würde zum Beispiel, ist schon spannend, ne, zu sagen, okay
da kann ich da hinten, wo ich so sechs Grad wärmer wärmer habe, äh vielleicht doch schon mal eine Feige anbauen oder so, ne? Äh ich
da irgendwo wurde irgendwie äh äh kalt ist oder so, da ist vielleicht die Feige jetzt nicht so der Baum, der da äh vielleicht eine Chance hat, weil 6 Grad ist schon,
Also gerade eine Feige ist da ein gutes Beispiel, weil die kommt ja auch notfalls wieder aus ähm Wurzeln raus, wenn der Boden halt warm genug ist. Und da kommen halt
ne, hängt da zusammen, wo der Wind lang geht, wo die Sonne langgeht. Ähm dann gibt's da diese Mauer rundrum, die halt auch ein bisschen wärmer abstrahlt und so, ne, also das sind alles so Mikroklima, die ich denn da auch gelernt habe.
Feingliedrig hast du dieses Temperaturnetz ausgespannt, also alle paar Meter oder alle 50 Meter, alle 1hundert Meter.
Zwei Hektar, habe ich 21 Punkte so relativ gridmäßig verteilt, also von so Stellen, wo die interessant waren.
Ja, also vom Gefühl her, sage ich mal, hier könnte ich mir mal vielleicht was vorstellen, weil eh offen ist, kleine Bäume wachsen, da mache ich mal so einen Spot. Ähm.
Oder da mitten im Wald irgendwo mal auch.
Passiert ja bald eigentlich mit der Bodentemperatur auch. Schwankungen im Jahr so, ne? Also auch zu sehen, dass so die extremen also Lufttemperatur
versus Bodentemperatur im Wald ähm
da kann halt 40 Grad draußen sein, hast den Boden halt immer noch relativ kühl so, ne. Also diese Gegensätze auch zu sehen, das ist äh hat mir sehr viel sehr viel Einblick über
und generell geschenkt. Ja ähm genau, dann gehst du übers Grundstück und
guckst so oder was wächst auch gut, ne? Wie sehen die Bäume aus? Haben die vielleicht ein Wind schiefen? Ne, also wenn die Bäume irgendwie alle schief sind, dann ist klar, hier ist krasser Wind von einer Seite, hatte ich jetzt die glücklicherweise nicht weil rundum so ein bisschen Wald ist.
Aber äh soweit kann man da alles durch Beobachtung wirklich und kriegst du nicht neben deinem Grundstück live, ja. Ähm.
Deswegen sind wir jetzt so ein kleiner
kleiner Ausschweif hier an der Beobachtungsstelle. Wir gehen da gleich weiter durch den Designprozess. Ähm deswegen sind wir jetzt auch vor einer Permakultur drei null angekommen, ein lebender Designprozess.
Wo jetzt nicht mehr der Permakultur Designer auf dem Grundstück kommt und dort ein Design für jemand anders macht
das war sehr lange Zeit so. Äh was jetzt passiert ist eher, dass der Permanent Kulturdesigner auf ein Grundstück kommt und die Menschen, die dort leben und dort was tun wollen, unterrichtet darin, wie sie selber designen. Weil nur sie können diese Beobachtung machen und nur sie können diese verstehen dieses Grundstück so gut ähm
wie der Designer niemals verstehen wird so. Ähm.
Genau und dann gehst du halt von der äh Beobachtung in die Analyse, also versuchst die Beobachtung wirklich so ohne Rückschluss zu ziehen erstmal zu machen. Ja also wirklich nur eine reine Beobachtung. Du schreibst auf, was
wie
was du siehst. Äh und dann gehst du in die Analyse und diese Beobachtung schwindet aber auch nicht nur aufm Grundstück statt, sondern auch in einem selbst, beziehungsweise in diesem Prozess, was will man hier überhaupt.
Ja ähm,
für mich war das natürlich wichtig, auch mich selbst zu zu leuchten, möchte ich vielleicht jetzt noch Werbung für Autos machen. Ähm nee, das ist eigentlich nicht okay, dann brauche ich auch wirklich eine Einnahmequelle, die auch.
Kurze Distanz, zumindest hier so ein Einkommen ermöglicht, ähm dass ich A lebe davon und B auch diese Umsetzung alle
finanzieren kann und nicht alles ist umsonst, sage ich mal, ähm um auch manche Sachen zu beschleunigen ist auch ein bisschen Geld auch ganz sinnfrei. Ähm
sitzen aber alle so Sachen, die im Designprozess schon in mir so als Beobachtung stattgefunden hat und dann analysiert man halt ähm,
Sagt uns das denn halt alles, net? Hier kommt man halt schnell drauf, okay, das ist knochentrocken, der Boden ist scheiße. Ähm hier wächst nichts.
Wir wachsen nicht mehr die Bäume richtig, ne, also gibt so ein paar Baumarten, die sich ja auch aussammen, das habe ich auch festgestellt, aber das sind wirklich so Baumarkten, die wirklich Extremstandorte können.
Ähm und ich muss damit hier mit diesem Grundstück irgendwie Geld verdienen äh und ich habe halt diesen komischen Ahornwald,
Macht man mit so einem Ahornwald auch, ne, also so meine Analysen dann äh zu sagen, okay gucken wir mal. Ähm.
Und für mich war es auch ganz wichtig,
zeigen, okay, mit wirklich wenig Input von außen. So, das hat jetzt auch so eine Messerschneide, weil in einer sozialen Permakultur ist natürlich ein Input von außen nicht mehr jemanden. Ich kenne hier jemanden, der bringt mir was, weil das eh über hat und ein
und Müll hatte. Das ist eigentlich schon Input von innen, ja? Aber es ist äh das will natürlich trotzdem schön möglichst wenig ähm,
Öl auszukommen und immer wenn die äh,
ankam. Es wird halt Öl verbrannt, sage ich mal. Und äh war von vornherein mein Ansatz.
Du meinst jetzt Transport.
Transportaufwand, genau, genau. Ähm.
Ja und dann habe ich halt analysiert und analysiert und geguckt und auf meine meine Dings geguckt. Also ihr sagt okay, ich habe auch nicht viel Fläche und ich habe auch nicht viel.
Wasser zur Verfügung, ja und ähm dieser mir immer erst zu allererst Wasser, dann seien mir Wege, weil das Wasser brauchst du ohne Wasser, aber existiert kein Leben. Dann sei mehr Wege, weil ohne Wege kommst du nirgendswo hin ähm ja dann,
kommt meistens Energie, weil bisschen Energie brauchst du trotzdem, designst du mit rein, das ist hier noch schwierig,
Teil musste ich nach hinten schieben wegen Bau Baugeschichten. Ähm und dann noch einen Shelter, du möchtest da auch leben, also wenn du da leben möchtest, äh aber irgendeinen Shelter wäre schon nicht schlecht.
Und dann designste eigentlich erst so Bäume, Landschaft und so weiter, weil wenn es det alles nicht hast, brauchst du auch kein.
Okay, das ist jetzt im Prinzip die Kette äh nach dieser intensiven Beobachtungsphase, die quasi erstmal so eine Art Bestandsaufnahme ist, ne
so was was was ist hier, was wächst hier, wie verhält sich das, wie verhält sich das äh übers Jahr äh hinweg, was passiert hier, was passiert hier auch nicht, welche Tiere sind hier, was nimmt hier irgendwie Einfluss und dann eben solche Rahmendaten wie diese Temperaturmessung, Feuchtigkeit et cetera. Das schafft
dann quasi erstmal so ein so eine so eine Grundlage äh äh auf der man überhaupt erstmal alles in Bezug setzen kann und gegebenenfalls passende Entscheidungen fällen kann. Dann hast du gesagt Wasser ist dann
quasi schon der der zweite Schritt oder.
Da sind wir ja so in meinem Design, eigentlich diese dieses also ne also Beobachtung, Analyse, Design, Feedback ja also.
Was ist dann kommt jetzt die.
Die Analyse äh schon ein Geheimnis ein bisschen übersprungen ist auch nicht so meine Stärke ist, weil ich meistens nämlich die Beobachtung mit der Analyse mische,
kann man machen so jetzt mal die ganzen Erfahrungen, die jetzt so mit Designs gemacht haben, meine meine Tutoren, die wahrscheinlich hören wird, die hauen, ne. Ich versuche das nämlich aus mir rauszuprügeln.
Ähm aber wirklich äh möglichst beobachten, ohne ohne dort äh eine Wertung reinzulegen und dann eine Wertung
darauf zu machen auf die Beobachtung, ja. Also zu sagen, okay, ähm hier wachsen nur rote Eichen und Hopfenbuchen und dann zu sagen, okay, da wo Rotweichen Buchen mag, sonst die Erde besonders schlecht und das ist besonders trocken.
Wahrscheinlich Roteichen wachsen hoch
lassen, aber im Prinzip das wäre so oder äh zu sagen ähm hier bilden sich keine Pfützen, das ist die Beobachtung, ja und daraus zu schließen, na ja, der Boden musste extrem durchlässig sein, das ist dann die Analyse dazu sozusagen, ja?
Schon vorher, weil Brandenburger Sand zieht ja alles weg.
Brandenburger Sand zieht alles weg, ja, aber es ist doch sehr lokal. Ich habe jetzt hier ein anderes Projekt, wo ich ein Design tatsächlich für gemacht habe, äh die hier im Nachbardorf äh sitzen und die haben halt zwei Meter Lehmboden tatsächlich
Ja, also es ist schon, das kann man, natürlich ist gut durch die Geologie zu wissen, also auch eine Beobachtungsgeschichte zu Researching, das ist geologisch hier
äh vorgefallen in den letzten zwei Millionen Jahren. Ähm das sieht man auch in der Landschaft, ja schon deutlich ein Sander hier. Ähm.
Vor allen Dingen da oben ist noch eine Wanderdüne und so, also da sieht man dann spätestens.
Dünen gibt's hier.
Äh ja der größte Inlands in Europas war's meist nicht mehr mittlerweile bewaldet die wieder. Ähm ja aber gesagt, also kann man jetzt nicht von AS gehen, muss man schon es ist eine Beobachtungsgeschichte. Kann man natürlich auch eine Bodenprobe nehmen. Ist auch eine Beobachtung, ne? Also ähm wenn man's.
Aber zu sehen, wie wenig Wasser hier wirklich, also wenn ihr wirklich so sechzig Millimeter pro Stunde Wasser fallen hast, sonst bilden sich nicht mehr Pfützen, dann weißt du, du hast Kiez, also du hast wirklich groben Sand mit wirklich
gröberen Steinchen auch drinnen, der wirklich einfach also wirklich das geht halt das fällt nach unten neunzig Grad das Wasser, das fällt von oben bis runter in die Wasserschicht und die ist so bei.
35 Meter, 40 Meter. Ähm.
Okay, also es fassen fasse ich's nochmal anders zusammen. Also im Prinzip der Prozess, Prototopia aufzubauen fängt,
Beobachtung an und mit dieser Analyse weiter, nur dass es vielleicht nicht unbedingt immer so ein getrennter äh Prozess ist, sondern mehr oder weniger 1 ist, aber ist ja klar. Man man erfasst erstmal die Situation und dann macht man sich einen Rahmen draus, warum sind die Dinge so, warum ist es jetzt da trockener, warum ist es da
wärmer etcetera um einfach auch die Gründe zu ja,
bereitzulegen, sofern man da sich jetzt immer einen Reimen drauf machen kann, mag ja auch das eine oder andere Mysterium bei übrig bleiben.
Wenn das abgeschlossen ist, dann geht man in die Design-Phase über, dann sagt man, okay, jetzt mache ich mir einen Plan,
Was will ich jetzt hier eigentlich bauen? Wie bringe ich quasi eine Produktion von Nahrungsmitteln in Einklang mit dem, was hier an natürlichen Prozessen ohnehin schon stattfindet.
Beobachtet, also was was ist hier vorhanden auch, ne, also wie kann ich mit dem arbeiten, was hier vorhanden ist. Entropie ist ein ganz großes Ding, also wie kann ich verhindern, dass Energie in sich in Luft auflöst oder Luft löst sich ja nie auf, aber äh,
unbrauchbar wird, sagen wir und Energie ist auch Wasser, also Wasser fällt und und so weiter oben ist es umso mehr Energie hält es, vor allem so weniger Energie brauchst du um
zu pumpen et cetera. Ähm.
Genau und dieser Designprozess aufm Land. Also wir reden jetzt wirklich von einem landbasierten Design. Ähm das ist bei hier jetzt bei meinem Prototop ja nicht
unbedingt gleich das langbasierte Design. Ich habe erst mal ein Firmendesign oder ein Framework Design gemacht nach Christopher Alexander. Einige von deinen Mithörern.
Ihn vielleicht kennen aus Programmiergeschichten ähm der hat halt das Framework Design, war ein Architekt äh in den siebziger Jahren äh Time is Way of Building und the Pattern Language geschrieben und noch ein dritte
bewohnen,
aber die beiden sind die Wichtigsten und ähm in diesen Timelastery of Building hat er etwas von einem Framework Design geschrieben, was später für
Programmierung benutzt wurde, aber ich jetzt hier auch auf Permakultur angewendet habe, zumal die Permakultur auf diese zweite Buch sehr.
Wirklich im Detail-Design dann auf das zweite Buch sehr äh doll zurückgreift, dieses Pattern-Language und ähm genau und da geht's halt darum, okay, wie funktionieren meine wie würde hier diese so eine Firma funktionieren so und da ist natürlich auch die Beobachtung, was ist hier auf dem Grundstück
und ähm,
Ja, prinzipiell, wenn aber wie lassen einfacher ist dieses Land passiert, dass sie sein, lass uns dabei bleiben, also das ist das, was auch die meisten mit Permakultur so verbinden so. Und in diesem Land basierten Design fahren wir immer zuerst an Wasser zu designen und das ist hier natürlich.
Nochmal extra wichtig, genau. Ähm.
So und dann guckst du dir halt an, was hast du denn hier so? Äh an Wasser. Ähm ne Oberflächenwasser hast du so gut wie null. Also du kannst natürlich einen Teich bauen, ne? Kommst du wieder in den Teichbau, Folien, Scheiße so, viele Permakulturprojekte auch gesehen, wo sie mit,
gebaut haben, die sie leer waren, weil die Spielmaus von unten kamen und noch eingebohrt hat. Ähm äh so Mäuse ist natürlich äh voll hin und weg. Wenn,
Kann man machen, ne? Kann man auch Leben reinholen, äh kann man auch Teilchen natürlich abdichten, aber will man in Teich. Ist ein extremer ähm Energieaufwand, ja, ein bisschen Oberflächenwasser brauche ich für Vögel, Kröten et cetera, wäre schon geil.
Ist aber grade nicht ganz oben auf der Umsetzungsliste bei mir, aber wird's auch geben. Ähm aber ich habe halt,
Wasser fällt halt neunzig Grad nach unten und ich habe einen, da gibt's da gibt's eine Schicht, wo das Wasser stehen bleibt und.
Hat es einen Energieaufwand det hochzupumpen, aber es ist ein wesentlich kleiner Energieaufwand als hier Terraforming zu machen und die Erde so krass zu verändern, dass sie Wasser hält, also Wasser.
Wasseroberflächen was er mir gibt zum Gemüsebewässern brauche ich halt tatsächlich Oberflächenmaß.
Kann ich noch Wasser halten mit organischem Material so ähm deswegen gibt's hier sehr viele in meinem Design sehr viele ähm Elemente, die mit organischem Material Wasser halten.
Soweit, dass ich in die,
Beet rein, also da, wo man lang läuft, zwischen die Beetereien, äh die Wege. Ähm tatsächlich Baumstimme vergraben habe von den toten Fichten, die sich ja sowieso äh gestorben sind und ich nicht wusste, Kerl kann ich verbrennen, ist aber so.
Entropie verbrennst es weg.
Noch ein bisschen Nährstoffe übrig, aber ist minimal, aber es ist einfach weg. Viel geiler ist das da, die Wege zu legen. Da ist das Habitat zuführe.
Regenwürmer, et cetera, aber es ist vor allen Dingen ein Megaschwamm. Und zwar richtig krasser Schwamm. Ähm kommen noch ein paar Holzhackschnitzel mit dazu, die teilweise auch selber machen, teilweise auch noch anfahren lasse.
Aber ähm im Prinzip baue ich hier Schwämme. Da gibt's dann auch noch so große Cremen, wo.
Bäumen daneben wachsen und in den Gräben sind auch Baumstämme und alles organische Material, was ich so finde und wir bringen ja Leute mittlerweile auch gar nicht Material, weil sie nicht wissen, wohin damit. Ist geil, ja, auch Permakultur, ne, also von einem anderen den Abfall weiter zu verwenden im Prinzip.
Mhm. Weil diese Bäume sind ja sozusagen unter den Laufwegen zwischen den Beeten, quasi einfach.
Erde einfach einen Baum rein, einen dicken, fetten und der.
Monat natürlich dann auch irgendwann mal äh weg, aber das dauert ja auch sehr lange und ist dann für ein paar Jahre einfach so ein Schwamm, weil wenn's mal regnet, dann zieht es auch sofort in das Holz und bleibt da lange drin und gibt es dann wiederum stückweise ab.
Genau. Also auch wenn die wenn die Wässerung mal nicht an ist oder so, habe ich dann wesentlich ausgeglicheneret äh Wasserhaushalt in den ähm muss beregnen, ja und äh komme mal wieder darauf, dass das Wasser hier 90 Grad runterfällt und ich habe halt,
ist für mich die einfachste Wasserquelle, der war einfach zu Wasserspeicher ist da unten muss ich mich nicht gegen wehren, ja? Das wäre dann wirklich ähm.
Finde jetzt wahrscheinlich nicht die mollischen äh Prinzipade im Prinzip für. Äh man soll sich nicht gegen so einfache Lösungen, ne? Also ist halt auch eine einfache Lösung. Ähm äh genau.
Mit dem Solarpanel dann auch wieder mit wenig Energieaufwand, weil die Sonne auch ähm habe ich noch nicht wie ein Bau,
Geschichten, die ich nicht darf gerade, aber ähm im Prinzip da will ich hin, autark kocht das Wasser nach oben zu pumpen, dann stört's mich nicht, dann ist wirklich nur noch die Pumpe selber herstellen, das größte Energieaufwand in diesem
in diesem System. Viel geringer als wenn ich hier einen Riesenteich, wenn man hier wirklich mit Gemüse zu bespielen, Bräuche gerade einen Riesenteich, wo ich auch,
wenig Zulauf habe auch wieder, ne? Also ich gleich kein Oberflächenwasser habe, läuft da auch nichts rein. Klar, wenn jetzt irgendwie so am Lebenhang wohnst, baust du in ihren Damm und dann läuft das Wasser dann und so. Ähm genau und äh.
Denn det ist so Wasserdesign, also da müsste man jetzt hier kann man kann ich dann
nicht zeigen, wie das dann hier so im Groben aussieht. Natürlich auch Abwasser, ne, dass man hier eine Biokläranlage baut, die glücklicherweise bauen darf. Ähm ist noch nicht fertig, aber die darf ich bauen und das ist auch eine offene Bioklänlage, wo relativ viel Biomasse.
Entsteht aber auch überflüssig Wasser dann hinten rauskommt, womit ich nicht Gemüse bewässern darf. Natürlich liegt auch nicht wegen Keimen et cetera, aber Bäume.
Damit schon durchaus bewässern, möglichst passiv dann auch um die um die Biokräranlage herum.
Ähm und jedes Fitzelchen Wasser, was hier irgendwie kommt, irgendwie auffange und halte beziehungsweise das, was nach unten fließt, auch wieder nach obenpumpe.
Das war also jetzt Punkt eins dieses Designprozesses. Das steht ganz am Anfang, Wasser.
Also immer ohne Wasser kein Leben und das hat man jetzt.
Woran woran kannst du testen, dass dass dein Design dann auch ausreicht, also upsa.
Ich habe hier, ich teste ja wirklich auch alles, auch im Kleinen oder mal mache ich hier Testabschnitte, auch diese diese Creme mit diesen sogenannten swales, die.
Hier also auf dem Sandboden mit wenig Gefälle, also ich habe hier ein Prozent Gefälle, also wirklich ganz, ganz wenig Befehle, ist so ein klassischerweise nicht,
ja also klassischerweise nicht das, was man als Designelement.
Das muss ich mir heute Abend genau vorstellen.
Ist ähm ein ein Graben mit einem Hügel, an einem Hang
der Graben und Hügel ist auf auf der Höhenlinie, also man kennt ja die Karten, die haben so Höhenlinien, das heißt also immer an der gleichen Höhenlinie lang, also sprich da gibt's kein Gefälle in
und dann fließt das Wasser also theoretisch fließt das Wasser an dem Hagen herunter in diesen Graben hinein,
hält sich dort auf diesem Hügel, sind Bäume gepflanzt und die ziehen sich det Wasser aus diesem.
Aus diesen Graben raus ein Stückchen nach oben dadurch, weil agieren wie eine Pumpe und dann fließt das Wasser.
Oberflächenmäßig ab ins in den nächsten ähm.
In den nächsten Fluss und dann ist es weg, geht ins Meer und irgendwo hast du noch eine Überschwemmung, sondern es geht in die Erde sickert langsam ein und geht dann unter der Oberfläche der Erde ganz leicht äh weiter,
und äh bewässert dir sozusagen noch den unteren Hang auch in trockenen Zeiten,
So. Das ist eigentlich ein Trail. Äh ich mache den hier auch. Ah ist ein schönes Design Element, irgendwas auf einer,
Schönheit ist auch ein bisschen wichtig äh finde ich äh immer äh auf dieser Höhenlinie, diesen äh so son son äh so ein Graben mit so einem Hügel, wo Bäume draufwachsen, zu designen. Ähm äh ich mache diesen aber nicht ähm.
Dass das Oberflächenwasser da reinläuft, sondern ich äh tue in diesen Graben,
viel organisches Material und das ist ein sogenannter Schwammswehl, also äh Spunchwear. Also der wirkt dann wie ein Schwamm.
Ähm und funktioniert aber im Prinzip genauso, auch bei einem Prozent Gefälle fließt das ganz klein bisschen an
raus, ja? Das Wasser fließt wie immer nach unten fließen. Und äh den Teig probiert tatsächlich, ähm bevor ich das im größeren Stil hier gemacht habe.
Ganz Kleinen gebaut, der hat nicht funktioniert, da habe ich einen etwas größer gebaut, aber nicht sehr breit, sondern nur ein kleines Stück und dann kamen diese trocken, ja.
Die einzige feuchte Stelle auf dem ganzen Grundstück war hinter diesem Fell, war das Gras grün und hat nicht geknutscht, wenn man barfuß rübergelaufen ist. Also es war wirklich, es war so ein Aha-Erlebnis, sondern wirklich nur diese Stelle, ja. Also und,
du es halt beobachtest, also ne, also Feedback loopt ja ganz hinten am hinter dem Design wiederkommt, du beobachtest halt dein Design, kleine Lösung wieder, also man hat ja erstmal einen Kleinen gebaut, wenn es nicht funktioniert, hat der gesagt, okay, funktioniert ja nicht.
Ähm aber da funktioniert ganz gut. Mit dem Gemüse gleiche lässt das Jahr war ja so unstetig und da habe ich die Bewässerung irgendwann ausgemacht, weil von oben,
irgendwann auch der Salat halt teilweise dann wirklich um schwierig wurde von oben zu bewässern, weil 90 Prozent Luftdüchtigkeit die ganze Jahr lang eigentlich schwierig und,
Wasserhaut trotzdem ab hier in meinem Boden, egal wie viel Biomassage ich da aufgebaut habe oder so, das ist rauscht eigentlich, es rauscht einfach nach unten ab. Und ähm.
Äh der das Feld, wo ich mit diesem Baumstämmen gearbeitet habe, noch nicht alle Felder so, aber das Feld, wo ich mit dem Baumstamm gearbeitet habe
da war auch ist alles weiter ganz entspannt gewachsen ohne meine Oberfloh-Bewässerung auch in den zwei, drei Wochen, wo mal kein Regen dazwischen war. Wir haben bei den anderen Feldern,
schwierig. Da musste ich dann immer mal trotzdem die Besserung anmachen. Das hat mir wieder weggegammelt und so, ja. Hm, also ist schon deutlicher Unterschied zu sehen. Also vielleicht, dass ich och.
Den direkten Vergleich habe, ja. Und Beobachtung.
Hast du dein ideales Wassermodell jetzt sozusagen gefunden oder ist das so.
Es ist im Entstehen äh es ist im Entstehen, dass es sehr viel Erdarbeiten auch noch äh die,
Handmache alleine teilweise. Mittlerweile habe ich immer mehr Hilfe ähm äh auch meine Partnerin, äh die mir jetzt auch bei der Landwirtschaft hilft, aber so diese das buddeln.
Ist schon ganz schön. Also letztes Jahr hatte wirklich jemand, der mir auf so ein Bild äh so eine Gruppe von Leuten, die mir ins wehgebuddelt haben, aber mach dauert.
Ja, das ist äh ist auch körperlich,
challenging. Ähm bloß mit der Alternative ist hier wirklich große reinzubringen und ich habe hier so einen alten Bagger stehen, äh den ich am Anfang, der am Anfang noch funktioniert hat, der jetzt nicht mehr funktioniert und dann bin ich,
nur so halb und froh drüber. Es nervt mich ein bisschen das Diät, äh weil da noch rumsteht, aber man geht dat viel zu schnell damit was an. Man man kriegt kein Feedback. Man macht da halt einen riesengroßen
die Erde auf, riesen, breiten, irgendwas und dann funktioniert's nicht. Wobei man überhaupt nicht diesen Feedback
abgewartet hat, sondern macht vielleicht ein riesengroßes kleine und langsame Lösung, finde ich grade. Also
hat mich sehr lange gebraucht, wirklich zu machen. Wir haben eigentlich die Zeit nicht, weil Klimawandel drückt, aber det jetzt
ohne wirklich zu testen vorher so Sachen zu machen, bin ich komplett weg von und äh mache dann lieber, weil meine Mühe die Schippe in die Hand statt ein Bagger. Ähm ja und es wird auch Oberflächenwasser geben. Es gibt da zwei kleine Teiche geben, liegt wahrscheinlich
leben Venturnitmatten, Abdichte ähm einfach Waldkröten und so weiter brauchen det auch.
Aber mit dem Glaserdesign an sich bin ich zufrieden und auch ähm also die große Aha-Erlebnis war.
Allet an organischem Material auf diesen Boden lassen und äh ne, also geht so weit, dass ich zwar hier mit heize, also aber mit teilweise ein wirklich.
Holzbriketts kaufen. Ich weiß jetzt nicht ganz ökologisch und äh ethisch nicht jetzt das Allerreinste, aber
bring's nicht über Herz, Herz hier die großen Bäume zu zerhacken und ihn in den Ofen zu schieben. Ja und ich kaue die lieber hier hinten und mache daraus Erde, ja weil,
sehe, was da passiert auch. Also was da auch an den Bodenlebewesen passiert und alles, also ähm da rund rum ist auf einmal richtig Leben so, ne und die Kapitelstellen im Grundstück.
Da wachst mal ein Ahorn drauf, ja aber rundrum ist halt wirklich Wüste, da kommt wieder da oben, da kommt der Unterboden durch mittlerweile, ne, einfach,
aber auch Landwirtschaft früher, die haben auch viel Boden wahrscheinlich auch kaputt gemacht, sie hat auch mit ihren Apfelbäumen wahrscheinlich nicht ganz lieb, übervoll mit dem Boden rundrum umher und ähm ja, zwei, drei Stellen habe ich halt fünf Zentimeter Oberboden und wenn der weg ist, da.
Puren Sand. Da kriege ich auch keine Bäume mehr etabliert. Genau, anderet,
Nächste Wege und da ist jetzt nochmal schön, äh kann man jetzt natürlich auch nicht zeigen, äh guckt man halt verschiedene Größen von Wegen. Dit ist dann im Prinzip wie so ein Baum.
Hat man so den Hauptbaum und dann gibt's größere Äste und dann gibt's kleinere Äste und dann gibt's irgendwie, ne, endet man irgendwo in dem.
Warum es Wege jetzt so wichtig? Warum ist das schon nach Wasser der nächste Punkt?
Na ja, weil musste ja irgendwo hinkommen, um Baum zu pflanzen zum Beispiel. Ja oder musst du auch irgendwie äh dein dein Gemüse von A nach B kriegen?
Okay, also wir reden jetzt eigentlich sozusagen von der Strukturierung, was ist wo, also Wege heißt ja auch, da wo kein Weg ist, ist das dass es da, wo du sozusagen anplatzt. Also geht's im Wesentlichen so um die Struktur Wege und Anbauflächen.
Genau, also Anbauflächen noch gar nicht, ne, also halt äh Anbaufläche kommt dann auf später erst im Design.
Aber ich meine, da wo kein Weg ist, ist zwangsläufig.
Sind wir jetzt in diesen lebenden merkst du jetzt schon? Also wenn wir jetzt in diesen lebenden Designprozess wohl Permakultur drei jetzt hingekommen ist so ne also früher hat man ja hat man gesagt okay hier Anbauflächen da wie
Jetzt sagt man so, hm ja, da ist eine offene Fläche dabei. Es wäre schön, wenn da ein Weg hinkommt. Da könnte man irgendwas machen.
Ja und dann guckst du, wat kann man denn da machen, was passt denn da hin so und das ist aber nicht in diesem Hauptdesign mehr.
Verstehe schon, aber Wege ist sozusagen die Entscheidung, wo es auf gar keinen Fall irgendwas, weil da wird die ganze Zeit so äh rumgelatscht und da bleibt's halt einfach tot. Also im Prinzip du sortierst die tote Fläche aus.
Genau und sotierst auch äh Erschließung geht's da auch,
ne auch um um da muss man irgendwie sowieso mal hin ja und ähm.
Ist auch am Berg unheimlich wichtig, wie kommt man ne also auch umkippt Wasserkreislauf nicht zu stören, da gibt's nur an bestimmten Stellen, wo man Wege überhaupt,
Wie gesagt, das ist jetzt nur in dem Deine kann man jetzt auch nicht weiter ausführen, aber eine Sache, über jedes Element im Design hat mehrere Funktionen. Ist immer schön. Capi, mein Hauptweg, meinen neuen Eingangshauptweg, also den Stamm.
Ja, das ist jetzt nicht da, wo du reingekommen bist, sondern in der Mitte, sondern ein bisschen weiter hinten. Ähm den habe ich mal so.
Stacking Functional wirklich verschiedene Funktionen in den Weg gelegt und der ganze Weg ist ein, der geht halt an so einer Höhenlinie lang, der ist leicht, der ist relativ breit, weil da noch,
die mir Kompost liefern und so weiter da langfahren müssen. Das heißt, er ist auch maximal verdichtet, ähm sprich Wasser fließt dort tatsächlich auch bei einem stärkeren Regen. Ähm ist leicht gekippt, also es ist eigentlich ein wirklich mit,
im Graben, auch für original Idee. Äh das heißt das ganze Wasser, was da drüber um, wenn's gefroren ist sowieso und dann hat man wirklich da,
stehende im Frühjahr sieht man immer sehr schön. Ähm das heißt der Weg ist ein Weg. Der Weg ist ein Wasser,
Wasser ähm äh also Wasser halte oder Wasser äh auffangen, System ähm,
Baumsystem überhaupt an dem Weg entlang. Ähm,
Sollten ursprünglich wirklich ähm äh Bäume wachsen, die im Ertrag bringen, also die man einfach einfach nebenan in dem Weg langgeht, auch gleich die Äpfel pflückt, sage ich jetzt mal.
Aus mehreren Gründen äh schief laufen, weil ich da nämlich genau mit diesem Bagger da lang bin und nicht System halt beobachtet habe und man hätte die ersten zwee Jahre bewässern müssen hier, ja, aber egal, ist nochmal ein anderes Thema.
Gemacht.
Fehler werden gemacht.
Und ähm vierte Element ist halt ist ein Feuerschutz. Äh der Weg geht da lang, wo die haben eine Hauptfeuerangst herkommt. Also ich habe,
vom Süden und vom Norden sind meine zwei Hauptfeuerachsen. Ähm im Norden war eh mal Truppenübungsgebiet war vom Südenwald bergab Beet äh und dann fällt ganz unten, ganz, ganz unten am Wald ist, wenn da ein Feldbrand ist, weil die da mit ihrem,
rübergefahren sind, was schon passiert war einmal
äh kannst kommst du immer in den Banken den Berg hoch sozusagen und äh dieser Weg wäre würde im Prinzip im Norden diese Feuerachse zumindest einen Bodenbrand verhindern, weil es äh kann ich auch relativ schnell bewässern und da ist kein Bewuchs drauf, also
groß zum Gras drauf. Gemähtes Gras auch, weil man möchte ja doch langfahren und dann hast du auch Fahrspuren und so oder da kommt kein Feuer rüber
Und oben auch die Bankkronen dort, der ist so breit, dass die Baumkronen sich nicht berühren.
Äh das ist auch noch ein wichtiges äh Feuer, Unterdrückungselement, falls doch zum Bauen Kronenbrand bei Blätter, bei Blaublättern kommen sollte. Ähm.
Das heißt, in dein Wegedesign sind auch solche Aspekte wie Brandschutz quasi mit mit eingepreist.
Denke so, dass das so resilient ist, dass es jetzt hier irgendwie einen fetten Waldbrand dann auch äh in irgendeiner Form überstehen kann oder das ist jetzt erstmal einfach nur um irgendwie kleinere Brände zu motivieren und dann,
muss man Glück haben.
Feuerdesign wurde ja dann auch wirklich ähm wichtig, also das
wurde noch zu einem zentralen Element und da habe ich den auch gefunden, auch rausgefunden oder einige Sachen, die ich hier mache, die sind ja auch absolut Feuer unterdrücken, zum Beispiel bewässert das Gemüsefeld bitte
kein Feuer erfahren. Und äh so habe ich dann auch wirklich,
alle Gemüse also alle Häuser rum also vor allen Dingen geht ja auch rum da Waldbrand okay Bäume weg.
Ja, aber wirklich die Hab und Gut erstmal so zu schützen ist schon auch wichtig, dass man überlebt.
Mhm. Das heißt, die Beete sind auch eine Firewall sozusagen.
Die sind Firewall. Die sind rund rum äh Rheindesign noch nicht
ganz fertig. Eine Seite fehlt noch, aber grundsätzlich sind sie rundherum designt und äh dann ist wirklich rundrum ein Beweis, also ein automatisch bewässerndes System. Also da kann ich dann auch wegfahren, sagen, hier mach mal meine Bewässerung an und,
äh habe ich hier einen richtig großen Puffer. Also wesentlich größer als er empfohlen wird äh und dann ist die Chance, dass man ihn überlebt äh eigentlich schon ganz gut in,
auf den weil da sich nichts dran festhalten kann. Ähm keine keine,
Dachrin, das ist auch wichtig. Im Moment haben sie die noch, wegen nicht bauen darf, aber am Ende des Tages keine Plastedach rein und dann überlebst du auch so ein Feuer hier und also
jetzt vielleicht nicht drinne bleiben wegen Rauchentwicklung et cetera aber wir haben hohe Konfidenz, dass hier ähm das überleben wird so.
Äh sehr wenigen, wenn ich mir die meine Nachbarn angucke, die kiefern halt bis zum Haus haben, ne. Also das ist halt auch so Nadelhölzer sollte man schon zehn Meter ums Haus, definitiv wecken.
Bei 1tausend Grad hält dann auch das Haus nicht ab. Ähm genau ähm.
Also Wasser, Energie Bier, Sonnenwindenergie, Wind nicht so, weil wir leider im Wald,
ziemlich weit unten sind, sonst mehr Dat, meine Energie Lieblingsträge. Ähm.
Wasser so weit oben halten wie möglich, dann geht hier auch nicht, weil wenig Gefälle und so, also Energie ist ja auch ein Problem, sondern aber wir haben hier halt oft super viel Sonnentage, es ist komischerweise hier viel,
schlechtem Wetter, schlechtem Wetter, sage ich jetzt mal, äh zieht halt weg, deswegen sind wir ja auch so trocken. Und teilweise kannst du runter ins Dorf fahren, also Wolken und hier oben irgendwie nicht.
Wir reden jetzt im Prinzip vom dritten Designschritt Energie.
Ja. Energie.
Gut, ich meine äh du bist ja ein Stromnetz angeschlossen, nehme ich mal an.
Aber du willst äh möglichst wenig davon verwenden, wenn du deinen Energiebedarf niedrig hältst oder selber Energie erzeugst. Das kannst du jetzt noch nicht machen wegen Baurechtskram. Aber im Prinzip ist das so das Ziel.
Genau, also auch Gebäude dämmen und so. Das gehört da alles unter diesen Aspekt. Energie,
war jetzt ein müdes Stichwort, natürlich klar, Energie sparen steht noch viel weit oben als äh Energie erzeugen. Kurze Wege ist auch Energie, ne, also zu sagen, wo mache ich denn meine äh Stationen, wo ich die Gemüse wasche und
so, ne? Stelle ich die irgendwie ganz hinter, Ende vom Grundstück oder stelle ich die in die Mitte? Äh von allen Feldern. Äh.
Erstaunlich erwägt mir so andere große LPG's und so,
wäre schön. Also alle in dieser Aspekte klingt so banal, ne? Schöner das meiste ist total banal. Man denkt so, wenn man das so ausspricht und jemandem erzählt,
Ähm dit ist so was von einleuchtend. Das das machen doch alle. Nee, das machen eben nicht alle.
Wirklich auf so LPGs fährt und so. Ey da steht wirklich dit
Silo irgendwie steht irgendwie ein fünf Kilometer von den Hauptfeldern entfernt. Ja warum dat denn, ne? Was soll denn der Scheiß? Die fahren den ganzen Scheiß dann irgendwie zu diesem Silo hin und dann ne.
Also 00 drüber nachgedacht, dass man wirklich auch so Wege verkürzt und irgendwo Energie sparen und viele, ne? Also Energie sparen großes Thema. Wo platziert man was.
Wie dämmt man, wie ne, also jetzt hier Frühanzug ähm äh kann man mit der Frühanzug vielleicht gleich noch das Haus wärmen, ne? Das ist halt auch also im Frühjahrs
um früher aufs Feld zu kommen, muss man halt schon im Januar, Februar die ersten Pflanzen ähm aussäen äh die brauchen Hitze, die brauchen Licht. Ähm.
Ist halt okay, was macht man? Natürlich ein Gewächshaus. Ja, ist geil, wenn das Gewächshaus natürlich auch noch mit am Haus sind, weil Sonne schien einen drauf,
beamtet die Wächshause, wärmt dann auch gleich das Haus mit,
so, ne? Also mein Bauer, meinem geliebten äh ist auf der Südseite ein Annähengewächs hat, Annähen gewechselt, kann einen Bauantrag wieder äh kann keiner was mit anfangen, heißt dann im Wintergarten, brauchen die wieder spezielle Bogen in Deutschland.
Baurecht unheimlich hinderlich für alles, was wir hier machen in der,
ganz schwierig also auch Naturteich brauchst 'ne extra Genehmigung darfst du eigentlich wieder nicht weil wieder Wasserspiegel wieder in Verbindung kommst und so weiter also egal wo du rein liest nie Gesetze, kommst du auf.
Können wir bis Schritt weitergehen.
Ick habe ja dann natürlich gesagt, okay ich will hier ein Output bringen, der mir auch ein Leben ermöglicht. Da kam ich dann relativ schnell auf Gemüse, weil det war aber relativ schnell auch ein Output bringen. Ähm,
hätte das aber nur ein Element. Äh das zweite Element sind Pilze und der dritte Element sind Baumschule. Ähm und äh.
Äh diesen drei Elementen will ich halt dann äh am Ende des Tages wirklich ein ein Einkommen generieren. Äh Gemüse läuft schon seit vier Jahren sehr gut auch und habe sehr guten Absatz hier grad im lokalen Restaurants. Ähm.
Pilze sind in einer großes Element, weil die Pilze sind ja wirklich ein sehr zentraler Aspekt, um wirklich eine Kreislaufwirtschaft zu erzeugen, also wirklich keinen großen Input von außen zu haben. Möchte die Kim meine Ahorns in einer Niederwaldkultur.
Betreiben, ja. Niederwald wurde seit 2000 Jahren vor allen Dingen auch in England, aber auch hier in Deutschland äh betrieben. Ähm äh als Waldwirtschaft, easy, ja? Also man hat halt Bäume genommen, hat die,
geschnitten und gewartet, bis sie wieder austreiben. Äh das kann man mit einigen Bäumen im,
besseren Böden äh kann man 34.000 Jahre mit dem gleichen Baum machen. Er wird nie sterben.
Ist halt cool, weil du musst nicht immer wieder einen neuen, du hast gerade von erzählt, deine Apfelbäume sind alle eingegangen. Äh ne, das ist halt schwer, einen Baum zu etablieren, auch gerade auch in in Zeiten von Klimawandel. Wenn da ein Baum schon da ist, der treibt immer wieder auf.
Geiler Scheiß so. Ähm das wollen wir äh ist halt die Idee
darfst im deutschen Wahlrecht nicht machen, gehst jetzt nicht voll sehen, gibt halt äh Kurzumtriebsplantagen, ähm die sind halt Landwirtschaft ähm die dürfen maximal sieben Jahre dort stehen, dann musst du sie ernten,
die die sieht man jetzt auch immer wieder mal auf irgendwelchen Feldern, dass da irgendwelche Weiden stehen, die irgendwie so ganz dünne sind und dann immer geerntet werden.
Und dann darfst du Wald pflanzen, den darfst du auch aber ernten bis zu 80 Prozent darfst du Kahlschlag machen, wenn du so Waldbesitzer bist. Ähm muss dann aber neu pflanzen und ein Stockaustrieb zählt nicht als Deutschland.
Heißt also, du hast eine Abstimmung, der kommt wieder raus. Ähm.
Unheimlich schwierig, ja also egal wo du reingehst, du stößt immer wieder auf irgendwelche Gesetze, die irgendwie dagegen stehen, ne? Also machen, machen viele.
Versuche mit den Förstern irgendwie zu reden, aber es sind halt alles Energie. Aber im Endeffekt
Ja, möchte ich hier halt so einen Niederwaldkultur machen mit den Bäumen, mit dem Holz, was dort produziert wird, möchte ich Pilze anbauen. Die Pilze würde ich natürlich verkaufen, sowohl als Heilpilze als auch als ähm essbare Pilze.
Ähm das was übrig bleibt ist Erde äh und mit der Erde.
Also ein Pilzkompost ist so der geilste Kompost. Also wenn Pilzkompost gut durchgegangen ist, es ist der geilste Kompass für Gemüsebau. Da ist alles drin, was Gemüse braucht, brauchst du nichts mehr von außen. Das ist.
Mit Pilzkompost, also ein Kompost auf dem Pilze wachsen oder.
Nee ähm äh Kompost
der aus den Resten entstanden ist, wo Pilze vorher drin gewachsen sind. Also ich mache jetzt die Hackschnitzel aus so einem Baum oder mache die auch an richtig Baumstämme, dauert dann länger. Shiitake ist da so ein Beispiel. Kannst du direkt in den Baum impfen ähm manche Sachen,
damit sie schneller auch fruchten, machst du halt Hackschnitzel, Impf da die Pilze rein, erntest die Pilze, verkaufst die Pilze und dann hast du das übrig. Das ist ein Myce, Indien, in die Hackschnitzel sind dann schon sehr.
Vorbereitet. Das lässt du noch ein, zwei Jahre liegen, ja mit ein bisschen Luft mal. Muss vielleicht ein, zwei Mal umsetzen, aber kriegst dann daraus einen Kompost.
Da bleibt Erde übrig am Ende. Ist halt geil, Natur. Baum ja irgendwann mit dir zur Erde und die Erde, die dort rauskommt aus diesem Pilzprozess,
es gibt keinen Kompost, der mehr Nährstoffe drin hat, weil so ein Baum halt über die ganzen Jahre halt alle Nährstoffe zieht.
Aufpassen, der zieht auch Schwermetalle und so. Muss man aufpassen, wo man ist, machen wir schön Boden rummachen, wenn man aus einem schwierigen Standort ist oder nicht weiß, was vorher war. Aber ähm das was übrig bleibt, im im Idealfall ist halt ein geiler Boden.
Und den würde ich dann nehmen zum Gemüse einbauen. Und irgendwann, wenn ich nicht mehr kann auf dem Gemüseverhältnis abzusehen, ich bin das auch nicht mehr der Allerjüngste, ja? Irgendwann schwere Arbeit dort draußen, sagt man so, die meisten, die das regelmäßig machen, haben dann auch
den Körper gut daran angepasst und schaffen det bis siebzig,
Ja, aber danach ist halt wahrscheinlich Feierabend. Und wenn ich dann keinen gefunden habe, der das halt übernimmt, also meine Tochter sagt, hm nee, Müse ist nie meins.
Zu zwingen, ähm dann mache ich instant wieder zu weit,
aber in dieser Zeit im unendlich geilen Boden aufgebaut und ich mache jetzt schon der Kompost, im Moment kommt noch von außen, weil ich
der Niederwald auch noch nicht, wie gesagt, noch nicht darf und das alles kompliziert. Äh ich darf vor allen Dingen auch keine Pilze anbauen, weil ich dafür Infrastruktur brauche, eine Scheune, die ich nicht bauen darf. Äh
Ähm genau und ähm da ich das noch nicht machen kann, kommt im Moment der Kompost von aus, aber ich mache jetzt Moment.
Also das älteste Feld ist jetzt fünfeinhalb Jahre, wo ich Gemüse darauf anbaue und der Unterschied ist halt ein Unterschied, Gitarre nachts zu dem natürlichen,
Boden, ja, der hier so. Normalerweise ist der ja auch nicht so natürlich ist, weil man war halt ein Eichenwald drauf. Da wurde also Nelksander,
war eine Wüste danach, äh mit aber noch ein bisschen Lehmschicht oben drauf. Dann kamen Eichen, sind hier gewachsen, dann wurden die ganzen Eichen alle gekillt, weil man halt.
Damit gebaut hat, ja, Computerbock gebaut hat,
Da steht eine Kirche mit einem großen Dachstuhl et cetera. So viele Eichen boxen ja auch nicht, weil es schon Sandboden und auch Schamane geboten, aber gut, mal alle gekillt.
Wieder Oberbodenabtrag ähm dann hat man hier Apfelbäume noch raufgepflanzt, die hat man auch gefellt danach wieder, ne und am Ende,
ist hier nicht sehr viel Bodenleben drinne und auch nicht sehr viel Oberboden und noch nichts wertvolles groß an Oberboden da. Ähm ich habe jetzt wirklich innerhalb von sechs Jahren fast,
15 Zentimeter Oberboden auf dem ältesten Feld äh gebaut. Also das ist wirklich eine Riesenschicht schwarz, tiefe Erde. Das ist jetzt wie gesagt ein 20.000 Jahren oder weiß nicht, wie wir letzte äh letzte Eiszeit war ähm länger her, aber äh
ist halt hier so. Wir reden hier insgesamt über 20 Zentimeter. Der Körper ist in Oberboden fast verdoppelt.
Wenn ich jetzt da die Müse aufhöre natürlich immer weiter ja also Boden aufbauende Landwirtschaft nennt man das auch heutzutage ähm wirklich Boden aufbauen und Wirtschaft statt die zu zerstören geht doch anders. Ähm
und wenn ihr den irgendwann nicht mehr will und nicht mehr kann, pflanzt sich Instant Bäume drauf und dann kann ich halt wirklich aus dem gesamten Repertoire der Baumbäume halt auswählen, weil der Boden einfach.
Hergibt, ja.
Ja und,
Bäume, die dann auch Essen abwerfen für eine nachfolgende Generation, ne, ähm die dann irgendwann mal nach mir kommt und vielleicht jetzt sehen, wie geil das eher ist, dass man einfach.
Liegen kann, den Mund aufmachen kann und dann fällt dem Hund Essen in den Mund. So, das ist so die Vision, die man so hat.
Dann lass mal äh weiterkommen im Designprozess ähm.
Also wir hatten jetzt klar, Wasser wir hatten äh Wege, hängt auch mitm Wasser zusammen, Energie ganz klar äh sparen, optimieren, ähm.
In der Zukunft gegebenenfalls halt auch noch durch nachhaltige Generatoren äh weiter Energie sparen, weil man sie ja nicht extern ranholen muss und eben dieses Prinzip dieser Kreislaufwirtschaft und des Bodenaufbaus.
Jetzt müssen wir ja auch irgendwann mal so zu den eigentlichen Dingen kommen, die du hier äh produzierst. Ist das jetzt schon so der nächste Schritt gewesen, dass du dann.
Shelter war bei mir noch und das kommt auf Design drauf an und nicht immer braucht man was zum Wohnen. Ich,
natürlich Watzen wurden, also Schelter, also auch ein eigenes Design eigentlich für sich, also ist schon von der Lokalisierung her in dem Landdesign an bestimmten Stellen hier vorgegeben, ja.
Baurechtlich et cetera et cetera, gibt's ja bestimmte Richtlinien und das heißt
ich muss die da haben, wo sie jetzt sind, nicht mein, aber man lebt damit. Aber wenn man jetzt äh in einem komplett neu macht und mal einen Shelter, dann wäre jetzt so in
wer zu der Punkt zu sagen, wo baut man jetzt so ein Haus auch hin, ne? Da gibt's halt auch tausend Möglichkeiten, das zu beleuchten. Möchte ich jetzt bloß nicht möchte nicht anreisen, kann man sich einlesen. Es äh hat die Perbakultur wirklich grandiose.
Hintergrundwissen, also wie Häuser platziert werden, wie sie ausgerichtet
was man da wie man die bauen kann, mit welchem Materialien, äh möglichst lokale Materialien natürlich, aber es
auch ähm hm nicht nur in der Permakultur natürlich, da guckt die Permakultur natürlich auch nach draußen, ähm natürlich ist Bauen äh et cetera, ne ähm aber wir gucken halt, wie's Bauen wirklich auch mit wenig Energieaufwand, ne, also ist
ich habe jetzt hier keine Steine vor Ort, nur samt ähm hm aber ich habe viel Holz, ist vielleicht wirklich so ein so ein Holzbau hier äh wirklich aus so einem Lock, so eine halt
wahrscheinlich die erste Wahl hier, weil es genug Kiefern rundherum.
Auch Hanf.
Hier jetzt bei mir nicht, nee äh.
Und Brandenburg schon, ja.
Brandenburg schon, ja. Hanf zum Beispiel, aber halt Stro.
Ich habe so gesehen, dass so Bausteine aus Hanf eine extrem äh coole Idee sind.
Ähm Strohballen äh wäre hier auch noch so ne, gibt's so viele Felder, äh Strohballen fallen hier definitiv ab
Wobei irgendjemanden kann man vielleicht sogar für einen sehr schmalen Taler hier. Also mir wurden schon Strohballen überall geholfen. Willst du nicht ein bisschen Strohballen in die Kapieren, die ganzen Lager voll? Ähm ne, die waren leider zu.
Zu weich und zu nicht fest genug gepresst, um ein Bauhaus draus zu bauen, aber die großen Strohballen heutzutage modern, kann man schon durchaus ein Haus draus bauen, ist sehr, sehr geil.
Ähm energetisch. Äh muss man ja gucken, was was geht. Ähm das wäre Shelter, das wäre so der nächste Punkt und dann kommt man wirklich so, hä, was mache ich denn jetzt hier überhaupt? He, also was brauche ich hier? Was mache ich hier?
Das produziere ich hier.
Produziere ich hier. Da wäre dann wie gesagt eine Analyse festgestellt habe, okay, kapiert diese diese diesen Wald, den möchte ich gerne benutzen.
Was kann man mit Wald machen? Äh Ahorn, erst was man so denkt so oh geil, kann ich anzapfen so und das war die Lieblingsidee. Kann ich ernsthaft.
Ahornsirup.
Ach so, ah.
Ja? Ähm kann ich auch einen Sirup machen, ist leider kein Zuckerahorn. Ick hab's probiert mit dem Ahorn Ahornsirup zu machen, das schmeckt ekelhaft.
War dann halt nicht mehr so drinnen. Dann denkst du so, hm, kannst jetzt umweiden. Oh, Scheiße, dauert dreißig, 40, 50 Jahre, ist auch kacke. So ähm mache ich damit und äh dann kam's mir irgendwann mit den Pilzen und ähm das,
baurechtlich sehr, sehr spannend, weil für Pilze kriegst du so Punkte, wie du im Außenbereich bauen darfst und Pilze brauchst du ganz wenig Fläche und kriegst ganz viel Punkte.
Für sprich Pilze äh fühlten sich von vornherein äh natürlich an durch diese Infrastrukturproblemen
musste ich halt noch eine schnellere Lösung finden und da war halt wirklich
die Müse wirklich so diese Brückentechnologie, sage ich mal, die auch gut war. Die hatten mir auch viel nochmal gezeigt, wie Natur funktioniert und so. Das hätte ich wahrscheinlich die Pilze gar nicht so mitbekommen. Auch was was die Gruppe
Probleme sind in der normalen Landwirtschaft. Dadurch habe ich auch für mit den anderen Landwirten viel.
Kontakt gekriegt und so und äh konnte auch meinen nochmal viel reflektieren. Das hat äh war auch eine innere Lernprozess, der wichtig war, äh den ich da mit rein aus Versehen mit reingesehen habe, sage ich mal.
Hast du ja so ein bisschen diese Zielkonflikt auf der einen Seite musst du was produzieren, was dir auch jemand abnimmt. Auf der anderen Seite kannst du auch nur das produzieren, was dieser Boden hergibt.
Wie bist du denn da jetzt rangegangen? Wie wählt man denn jetzt aus? Was wächst? Ist das dann wieder so eine Beobachtungs äh Phase, dass alles mögliche mal anbaust und guckst, was dabei rauskommt? Oder weißt du eigentlich schon jetzt äh zu dem Zeitpunkt von
den Gegebenheiten, was eigentlich gut funktionieren müsste und kannst es dann vergleichen mit dem, was vielleicht auch Nachfrage erzeugt.
Na ja, also von der Flächengröße her, weil von Anfang an klar, ähm
Grains sind ja sowieso nicht möglich. Also klar, es gibt mittlerweile ganz kleinen Traktoren oder ganz kleine Harvester, so die so so Mähdrescher so und
so 75 Zentimeter Breite so übers Japan gibt
tatsächlich mittlerweile ist ja auch ganz cool, aber das wusste ich damals natürlich noch nicht, also das wäre auch eher so ein Witz, äh so ein Witzding. Ähm da kann ich auch nicht mehr konkurrieren, also erstmal grundsätzlich Sachen, mit denen ich konkurrieren kann so und das äh ist schon edel Gemüse, sage ich mal, ja. Ähm
Salate, weil Salate müssen
immer scheiße aus im Supermarkt, sind immer wabbelige, schlapprige ähm komische oft so, ne. Nicht immer, aber äh wie nimmst du nach Hause? Hast du einen Tag im Kühlschrank gesehen, so haltbar
und schlag mich aus. Ähm.
Genau, äh dann guckst du halt auch nachher Absatzmarkt. So, was ist denn hier der Absatzmarkt? Hm, das Land, also vor fünf Jahren auch noch so. Die essen hier alle Fleisch, heiße so, ne? Ähm ist so Landbevölkerung jetzt nicht unbedingt äh haben jetzt.
Ein Aldi, ein Lidl, ein Penny, äh ne? Äh das ist sind sie die großen Supermarktketten ähm dementsprechend ist auch so.
Sind noch nicht da, wo die Berlin jetzt ist, zeigen äh mit sehr diplomatisch aus. Wir drücken vor 5 Jahren nicht. Das hat sich stark geändert.
Mangel sozusagen.
Ähm so ähm genau und dann ähm.
Gab wenig habe kleine Flächen, äh liegst schnell auf dem Marktgärten,
Gärten gekommen. So ist dieses Anbaumethode. Ähm die ich hier benutze, äh fasst man heutzutage unter Markt,
Gärtnerei zusammen. Äh Mark Gardening in Englisch eigentlich schöner. Ähm also ein Anbau für einen Markt, einen Markt
auch einen schlechten, aber auch über die Überlegung falk nach Berlin, den Scheiß kriege unendlich viel Geld für. Aber dieser
Weg da nach Berlin, dann musst du die kühl dahin bringen und so. Das hat sie auch halt irgendwie nie gut angefühlt und ähm dann bin ich halt auf jemand gestoßen an sich äh gehörte Stone ähm,
nicht jo Urban Pharma Curta Stone ähm der ist ein bisschen in die.
Schwierige Corona-Ecke abgedriftet, sage ich mal, aber äh der hat auf jeden Fall.
Ähm äh herauszufinden, wenn man irgendwie sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr kleinen Flächen sehr sehr sehr viel anbaut ähm und der hat vor allen Dingen Restaurants beliefert und das war halt auch so das Ausschlaggebende, dass ich dann hier zu den einzelnen Restaurants gegangen bin und gefragt haben, ja wollt ihr gerne das Gemüse? Und äh
offen Türen eingerannt. Das hatte ich ja nicht erwartet. Also egal in welche Restaurant ich gegangen bin ähm haben wir gesagt sofort ja ich hab's noch so einen kleinen Bioladen hier.
Wird dich da reingehen, hast gesagt was wollt ihr geiles Gemüse haben.
Geldgemüse haben, ja. Ihr habt ein bisschen was mitgebracht so, ne, also dann nachher eins, wo das einfacher, mein Gemüse sieht halt auch richtig.
Geil aus, ne? Bisschen stolz drauf so. Ähm äh ne, also da brauche ich nicht mehr. Ich komme mit so einem Korb irgendwo an und alle sagen, ja einmal bitte.
Ist äh sage dann auch.
In euren Kühlschrank, guckt in zwei Wochen drauf, auf den Salat, kleine Schnittsalate. Also wir reden hier wirklich über Rucola oder so. Tut die zwei Wochen in eure Kühlung und dann,
dann reden wir nochmal und dann sagt er mal, ob ihr da haben wollt so.
Ne? Äh ist nach zwei Wochen tatsächlich noch so zum Großteil, ja, nicht immer, aber zum Großteil immer noch so, dass den auf dem Teller im Restaurant packen kann, also dass der Standard nochmal höher als zu Hause, ja,
ähm hier mein mein Lieblingsrestaurant äh in Jüterbog. Gerne gerne ein bisschen mehr Augen. Äh die sind äh.
Er selber steht in der Küche und sein Bruder ist der Kellner und mehr gibt's nicht in den was zu sagen und die machen wirklich geilste Essen überhaupt um ein bisschen experimentierfreudiger heute und er sagt halt passiert mir immer wieder, dass ich halt irgendwo in einer Tüte von der Insalade Urlaub und er machte
regelmäßig im Sommer zu äh und komme ich halt wieder und dann ist halt diese Tüte noch und ich mache die uff und,
besser was ich in Großmarkt kriege nach zwei Wochen, drei Wochen. Ähm det ist halt cool äh aber wie gesagt, sie ist ähm waren halt meine Hauptabnehmer und die wollen halt sehr hochqualitativen Gemüse haben, vor allen Dingen Sachen, die
ähm sie so schwer kriegen, haltbaren Salat ist da ganz oben bei denen.
Weil natürlich nicht Augen abschätzen können, wie viel Gäste sie haben und unser Salat jetzt vier Wochen hält, ist für die auch mehr wert, weil die müssen nicht nach drei Tagen einen neuen Salat kaufen,
und ihn wechsel.
Dann wieder keiner benutzt, ja.
Genau. Ähm deswegen habe ich da offene Türen eingeladen. Das war cool. Das war wirklich ähm und habe wir liefern mittlerweile hier in einer wirklichen Umkreis von,
dreißigjähriger dreißig Kilometer, 30 Kilometer sind nur 30 Kilometer wirklich ähm sämtliche etwas.
Bessere Restaurants, also den Billiggriechen jetzt nicht, die sind natürlich an Preis interessiert und dann bin schon höher preisig, sage ich mal, aber die anderen.
Die anderen äh beliefere ich eigentlich alle und sind alle sehr glücklich. Ähm mittlerweile auch ein Franchise, Pizzaunternehmen, Call Pizza?
Ja ähm Franchise, der kann ein bisschen selber überlegen, wo er sein Zeug herkriegt und der sagt halt unterstütze sie gerne lokalen Bauern, weil eben wenn da äh Schitzhitze-Fan äh habe ich noch erst letzter Salat anzubieten,
Ja und äh sehr cool, weil er nimmt eine bestimmte Kontingent jede Woche ab.
Bin ich happy, vollen Preis bezahlt, äh weiß es zu schätzen, meckert nie. Qualität ist immer, findet da immer super, ja? Ist halt ähm.
Jahr durch Corona äh die die ähm Restaurants oder ganze Gastro hat ja ein bisschen gelitten bis auf diesen Pizzertypen. Äh der jetzt noch erweitert, äh haben die anderen ganz schön gelitten, deshalb merkt man auch, ähm auch im Absatz und dann haben wir gesagt, okay ein bisschen zu mehr zu diversieren, die
Ähm also,
von wir redet, meine Partnerin dieses Jahr Mike jetzt noch eine weitere Person, die einen Tag in der Woche mitmacht. Ansonsten habe ich einen Großteil alleine gemacht. Ähm.
Genau äh diversifizieren wir ein bisschen und machen sogenannte Coops, das heißt also so Gruppen von Leuten, die gerne Gemüse bei mir kaufen wollen und äh bestellen halt einzeln individuell bei mir, kriegen aber insgesamt alles geliefert, ist eine schöne Kooper,
äh ich muss nicht einzelne Tüten verpacken und einzelne Mini-Tüten verpacken und 100 Gramm Salat in Plaste tun.
Die äh kriegen halt direkt Kontakt zu einem Bauern, sage ich mal und müssen sich nur das einzeln auseinander.
Was hast du denn jetzt so hier? Was wächst denn hier konkret? Was was also was was wird denn alles so äh so Salat ist jetzt auch ein sehr allgemeiner Begriff.
Genau, also im Prinzip wachsen tut's schon mittlerweile ziemlich alles, was in Gemüse so zu wachsen kann hier in unseren Breitengraden, ja? Also bis hin zu Paprika, habe ich
aufm Feld eine Reihe, ja? Ähm weil mein Boden mittlerweile gut ist
Also die neuen Feldern, wo ick jetzt noch kein Paprika einpflanzen, aber so in den alten Feldern kann ich locker schon jetzt mittlerweile Paprika machen. Also die
Bodenaufbau habe. Ähm kommt eher drauf an, was möchte
äh dort anbauen. Ähm einmal der Absatzmarkt, Salate, die Salatköpfe, sämtliche Art und Formen, äh kleine Schnittsalat äh
gehen extrem Nasiasalate, ist ein Kreuzblüter, ähm ist ist meine Spezialität hier über die letzten drei Jahre gewesen, jetzt haben alle Restaurant Asiasalat von mir, jetzt wollen sie alle was anderes.
Kam wirklich in den Markt überschwemmt damit. Das war wirklich interessant zu sehen, wie so was funktioniert auch. Ähm,
Sie haben gesagt, nee, ich gehe jetzt hier zu meinem Kollegen irgendwie, ne, steht halt der gleiche Salat. Ich dachte, ich mir eins. Für ein Alleinstellungsmerkmal. Ähm,
dieses Jahr ein bisschen mit den Salaten, dann gehen über den kleinen Schnitt Salat, die fürs Restaurant cool sind, weil sie greifen rein, tun das aufn Teller.
Sky ist gewaschen, alle zu waschen bei mir vorsortiert, also ihr guckt da schon einmal durch, ob da irgendwelche Nebenkräuter irgendwie drin sind oder so, die vielleicht giftig sind, um das,
ähm so eine Vogelmiere lasse ich da noch gerne mal drin. Ähm genau und äh ja ansonsten Fenchel äh Rote Beete, also je nach Saison auch kleinere
ähm kleinere Karotten. Es ist alles
weil's sehr schnell wächst, ist gut bei mir. Ich ernte viele Sachen sehr klein, diesen hochwertiger, schmecken sie besser und sind hochwertiger von den Nährstoffverhalten, als wenn der Dauer jahrelang da drauf lässt. Ähm und ich kann es, weil ich nicht kühl, also bei
geringeren Abstand zwischen
Feld und Kunde habe, ja? Durch diese Spanien, diese ähm Snackmöhren sind halt extrem teuer, weil.
Kommen hier schon an uns ein Gummi, ja ähm weil die irgendwie eine Woche lang unterwegs sind. Ich habe halt hier geernte mittwochs, donnerstags treffe ich aus, ne.
Also
ist frischer geht's nicht, ja? Und mit Mittwoch nachts ist bei mir in der Abkühlung sofort vom Feld geht es sofort in dem Firat gelungen, liegt nicht lange aufm Feld rum. Mir hat so einen riesen Acker hast.
Eine halbe Stunde vergangen und wenn du da dreißig Grad, 40 Grad hast, irgendwie verweckt die Halle in dieser halben Stunde, ja? Im Prinzip müsste es nur einen Kühlwagen über den Acker fahren, macht ja keine, so, ne, also ähm dieser
die Frischegrad geht halt extrem runter. Und diese schnelle ermöglicht mir wirklich in so einer Reihe bis zu viermal hintereinander was anzupflanzen,
Also äh ne so ein klassisches Feld
bestellst du halt einmal vielleicht noch einen Winterroggen rauf, irgendwie um einer Gründüngung drauf zu haben. Also ich kriege jetzt wirklich von klassischen Großbauern ähm Gemüsefeld, ja, der macht da irgendwie eine Gründung im Winter drauf, damit der Boden nicht offen ist, Bio.
Wohlgemerkt nicht Bio-Bereich lassen die Böden meistens offen. Ne und ähm machen grünen Jungen drauf und dann sehen sie da einmal Karotten.
Lassen sie dann da drei Monate drauf.
Mehr schaffen die nicht. Ja also das äh so. Das heißt, sie brauchen unendliche Flächen ähm mit ihrem Traktor. Wir reden immer, die Marktgärtner reden davon, da wo die anderen ihren Traktor umdrehen wollen, wie unser gesamtes Gemüse ein.
Ja? Ähm ist alles handgemacht bei mir. Ich habe keinen Truck. Ich habe einen Zweirad-Traktor, so ein ganz kleines Ding, wenn man hinterherläuft. Den benutze ich aber
eigentlich nur zum Bete-Anliegen ganz ursprünglich, dann nie wieder. Also das nur Kompost drauf, das mit der Schubkarre. So ähm schnell,
damit ich viel hintereinander und dann ist es halt extrem eng gepflanzt, deswegen auch kleine Sachen äh eher auch die auch eher kleiden, damit kann ich sie auch enger anpfl,
und ja da geht so alles. Also ich mache auch ein paar Tomaten im Gewächshaus, weil ich habe jetzt nicht so ein riesen Gewächshaus, deswegen äh ist Tomaten nicht so mein Hauptding. Ähm.
Ja, Solate, Fenchel, wat, was noch Kohlrabi, äh was schnell so alt wird so schnell weg oder wird lange aufm Feld stehen, kann ein ganze Jahr lang Knoblauch ist auch geil, funktioniert auch richtig gut ähm,
Ich mache auch noch Basilikum. Das machen sich bei den Restaurants immer nur die Basilikumspitzen oben. Da steht auch
dreiviertel Jahr oder konnte vorher noch ein paar Salate auf das Feld und hinten dran nochmal irgendwas anderes, aber im Prinzip hatte schon die Hauptzeit, das äh steht dann da der Basilikum drauf und dann
knippel ich da die Spitzen ab und so als Deko so sehr beliebt äh auch sehr hochwertig.
Ähm wir sind jetzt dabei so in den Randzonen auch im essbarer Blüten zu machen, aber das dann schon so. Produktive ran zu.
Essbare Blüten.
Ja so ähm,
Taglinie zum Beispiel, richtig geile essbare Blüte. Man sieht das also wunderschöne Blume, groß, orange und schmeckt,
großartig im Salat, sieht natürlich auch geil aus noch zusätzlich als Deko. Ähm aber Taglien
Ist wirklich also so gewesen bei meinem Lieblingsesparer Blüte gibt's auch noch tausend andere und so weiter, aber wir machen jetzt wirklich einen auf Tag Lilien hier, weil's einfach auch schöner aussieht und natürlich Insekten und so weiter nicht verkauft, sieht einfach schön aus und.
Insekten nehmen sich das gerne. Ähm ja
so ein Ranzoni wächst. Wir machen jetzt haben wir eine andere Ranzone, wo wir jetzt auch ein bisschen Unkrautkräuter machen, Vogelmiere und äh Sommerposteleien tatsächlich, weil das auch angefragt wurde vom Restaurant. Ähm
wo wir dann sagen okay, scheiß aufm Feld, aber ist cool, wenn wir das so anbauen können, wenn man braucht, ne. Das kann minimal ein bisschen Kompost drunter, einfach damit kein Unkraut durchkommt.
Vogel.
Ja. Super lecker, schmeckt extrem gut, viel Vitamin C. Sag mal Portulak äh es hat so ein fleischiges,
Kriecht so ein bisschen am Boden, ähm hat einen extrem hohen Salzgehalt von sich aus. Äh ist halt auch so eine Pflanze, wenn man zum Versalzen im Boden hat, zieht sein Salz wieder raus.
Sehr geil essen. Schmeckt auch gut. Ja. Ja, ähm.
Also wie viel unterschiedliche, kannst du das mal quantifizieren? Wie viel unterschiedliche Arten du jetzt hier produktiv raushaust, unabhängig jetzt von der Menge.
Schwer zu sagen. Äh guck mal zwischen 20 und 40, sage ich jetzt mal.
Also es ist eher so Richtung 20 als 40, fünfundzwanzig vielleicht. So vom Bauchgefühl her, ich habe nie zählt. Ähm es steigt
gießen wir divers, aber es ist nicht es gibt viele, die machen dann auch wirklich vierzig plus so, ja? Das mag ich nicht so. Ich möchte erst mal gucken, dass ich mit den Sachen, die ich jetzt hier
vor Ort habe, wo wirklich klar komme, Radieschen, ne, Mairüben, ne, also Mais hat man ja,
so ähm gucken wir mal, ob wir diesen ja den normalen nicht, aber äh Schwarzwurzeln äh gucken dann gucke auch immer, was funktioniert und was ähm äh,
hat auch zu viele zu viele ja Schädlinge oder so
Ähm und ja aber das ist halt dann nur dieses Element Marktkarten in dem oh, über gröberen Design. Ich habe mich letztens hier ähm Deutsche Welle haben einen Beitrag über mich gemacht und da gab's dann in den YouTube-Kommentaren nicht,
die Antwort da. Ja du machst deine Maske. Nein, ich mache der Marktgarten, das ein Element in meinem großen Permakultur-Design. Ja, das ist wirklich ein kleines Element
ist im Moment sehr groß, weil das ist mein Einkommen und da geht halt viel Zeit und Energie rein, äh wird gerade kleiner wieder, also,
kommen noch ein paar Beete dazu, aber ähm rein in meiner Prioritätsliste im Kopf wandert gerade wieder ein bisschen zurück, weil.
Funktioniert, also noch nicht ernst.
Kleene Ecken, die noch nie funktionieren. Äh aber nicht alles funktioniert immer. Jetzt hat man so einen Regen, ja. Letztes Jahr muss ich ja erst mal drauf einstellen und ein bissel was vergammelt einfach, äh weil einfach zu viel Wasser da war.
Ähm ach so, mein Wassersystem muss ich auch noch sagen, ist hochgradig automatisiert, also da tickt da aus dem Brunnenpumpe hat das alles ähm,
Computer gesteuert mit Open Springer hier für deinen Geeksmann, noch so ein Gig äh Ding hinten ran. Ob es bringt ja wahnsinnig tolle System, kann ich sehr empfehlen. Ähm
kann über Wetterdaten genau anpassen, wie viel Wasser wirklich aufs Feld muss, ähm ist ein Open Source Design, wird der Name schon sagt, kann man halt äh sowohl hardwaremäßig nachbauen, auch aufm Was,
mit einer kleineren Version. Gibt aber auch ein vorgefertigtes Ding ähm äh genau. Hoste halt.
Aus halt Ventile ran. Ich habe in jedem Feld wirklich alle allet verdrahtet so und
nutze wirklich nur das Wasser wirklich nötig ist. Aber letztes Jahr musste ich noch mal ein bisschen neu einstellen. Viel Wasser war eine neue Situation.
Jetzt ähm würde mich natürlich nochmal interessieren.
Wie man diesen Permakulturgedanken vielleicht auch gewinnbringend, also für sich und für alle anderen gewinnbringend nicht im Sinne von wirtschaftlich gewinnbringend ähm zum Einsatz bringen kann, selbst wenn man jetzt nicht vor hat damit seinen Lebensunterhalt zu
bestreiten. Viele haben vielleicht einen Garten, vielleicht haben äh manche auch einfach.
Einfach nur so ein bisschen Wiese im Hinterhof, keine Ahnung, es gibt ja immer diese Orte und immer diese Diskussion da drüber, wie man denn das jetzt richtig bespielt oder was man dort vielleicht nicht machen sollte, weil ja diese ganze Kleinökologie grade auch,
in den Städten durchaus auch Impact hat, ne. Das ist halt nicht nicht unwichtig. Also erstmal sollte es halt.
Grün sein, aber das ist halt die Frage, okay, jetzt haben wir hier die Möglichkeit, irgendwas zu machen wir denn jetzt. Gibt's da irgendwelche leeren aus der.
Aus dieser ja Permakulturwelt oder überhaupt aus aus deinem Ansatz oder dem, was du so ähm hier dir selber beigebracht hast.
Man da so mitnehmen könnte.
Ist schon ganz schön schwierig so, ne, weil jedes jedes System ist anders. Also bei Kai aber Design kann man halt auf alles machen. Das kann auch ein Balkon sein äh muss man halt so sagen.
Ähm grundsätzlich jeder, der so wirklich so wirklich mit so einem Gedanken spielt,
kann ich wirklich empfehlen mal so einen 72 Stunden Kurs zu machen. Äh man wird wirklich schlauer, eigentlich jeder. Ja, also ist wirklich
äh man geht wirklich mit einem Wissensding da raus, das ist äh das ist wirklich ähm Kopf erweitert ohne Ende, egal was, aus was für einer äh Dings man kommt. Ähm,
Ansonsten beobachten, beobachten, beobachten, gucken, dass Land oder dieses Stück Fleck
wirklich einem erzählt, ja? Das ist ähm äh nichts nichts ähm dem Aufdoktuieren, ja? Ich meine
sehr, sehr schwer zu sagen, ja, einer hat jetzt
20 Quadratmeter Golfrasen und der andere hängt an einem Berghang mit irgendeinem alten Weinstock so, das heißt also ich kann jetzt hier keine.
Werkzeuge in die Hand.
Ist ja auch klar geworden, ne, dass es dass es mehr ein Prozess ist und mehr eine Methode als ein du musst jetzt genau das machen, dann wird alles gut ähm ja und ich denke, das ist ja auch schon klar geworden, so die Beobachtung et cetera nur.
Es gibt ja auch kleinere Maßnahmen, die irgendwie oft greifen, so, ja. Also ich habe schon so das mit dem.
Mit dem Baumstamm in der Erde. Weißt du, so ich habe auch irgendwie so einen Garten und dann gibt's dann immer so eine Stelle.
Wächst irgendwie nix, da ist irgendwie keine Feuchtigkeit, dann will man das irgendwie ja, wenn man das jetzt irgendwie bewässern, hm ja. So, aber dann so einfache Sachen ähm.
Die einfach ja liegt auch da ein Stück.
Baumstamm, der da sowieso schon irgendwo rummodert, äh einfach mit rein und das könnte ja schon helfen. Das sind doch so ganz hilfreiche Tipps.
Ja. Also das sind halt Werkzeuge, ja und grundsätzlich ähm.
Kannst es auch mit Herangehensweisen vielleicht nochmal.
Also wichtig wichtig ist, viel Werkzeuge kommen ganz hinten, ja? Also für ein Werkzeug
Diskussion mit dir, also nicht Diskussion in äh einen Austausch und regener Austausch mit ähm Menschen, die hier aufm Bauwagen bei mir haben und hier auch mal mithelfen und Wochenende und die haben gesagt, wir wollen
Rasen vor ihrem Bauwagen haben so, ne und äh wie funktioniert denn das mit dem Rasen in der Permakultur? Also ja hm
schwierig ne, kam dann auch schon, ja gibt ja auch Magerrasen und so zu kaufen als Saatmischung und so. Ja ähm und da ist die große Frage, was wollt ihr denn überhaupt so und warum wollt ihr dann rasen und dich selber fragen warum? Warum? Weil
warum möchte ich denn jetzt hier überhaupt was machen mit dem System? Warum lasse ich nicht einfach die Natur machen, weil im Endeffekt,
Natur hat eigentlich immer so die beste Lösung von sich alleine, ja? Ähm manche Blüten sind halt so kaputt, dass die Natur da auch nichts mehr machen kann, aber selten. Selbst hier oben, ne, sind die Russen halt jahrhundertelang mit ihren Panzern durch die Wüste gefahren,
komplett von Vegetation freigehalten und hat jetzt, na ja, was haben wir jetzt 30 Jahre seit die Russen weg sind? Ungefähr. Ähm.
Und äh da fängt jetzt im Wald an zu wachsen. Er ist sehr tiefanlastig, weil natürlich die Menschen hier rundrum Kiefern gepflanzt haben und das ein sehr, sehr atgutem Boden ist. Aber immerhin, irgendwas wächst er schon, ja? Und da wird kommt jetzt zu so im Lauf der Jahre im Wald. Also im Prinzip.
Du nicht ungefähr erstmal grundsätzlich weißt, warum du da was machen willst oder warst du da auch,
ne grundsätzlich dir vorstellst so, ja. Aber nehmen wir an, du willst Essen produzieren. Das ist ja immer so das Grundding, ja. Du willst irgendeinen Garten haben, der schön ist,
vielleicht ein bisschen deine Kinder spielen kann und Essen produzieren kannst so ja und nicht möglichst mit wenig Arbeit so ja. Ähm dann würde ich erstmal gucken, was wächst da überhaupt,
bei dir auch im Rasen wirklich mit der Lupe mal reingehen, ja? Das ist ja schon mal ein schöner Anzeiger, ähm was du für einen Boden hast, da musst du keine Bodenproben machen, äh ne, wächst da viel Löwenzahnzahn, hast du einen verdichteten Boden, wächst da äh Boden
vorher jemanden Rasenfaktor immer jede zweite Woche rübergefahren hast, einen verdichten Boden zum Beispiel oder da stand wirklich mal,
eine Kuh drauf oder so, ne, wovor da irgendwie eine Kleingartensparte angemacht, hast du auch verdichteten Boden.
Verdichteter Boden, das höre ich jetzt raus, ist schlecht.
Dichter Boden ist schlecht, weil keine Luft im Boden und damit wächst wenig und äh kannste aber auch mitpflanzen wieder wegmachen, also kannst.
Manuell wegmachen mit der Doppelgrabegabe. Äh Doppelgrabegabe zum Beispiel. Ähm ja, ansonsten möchte man definitiv Bohnenaufbau betreiben, immer Bodenaufbau betreiben, ja? Ähm das kannst du mit
Mulchen machen, also wirklich die Pflanzen da sind einfach dort liegen lassen, einfach nähen und das nicht wegtragen,
wieder energiesparend auch, ja? Also was macht der allgemeine Gartenbesitzer, der fährt mitm Rasentraktor, verdichtet den Boden über seinen Rasen?
Äh und mäht alles ab und dann düngt dann danach, ja? Also diese Idiotie äh das Rasen, ich glaube es es gibt mehr Rasenflächen auf der Welt als Ackerflächen.
Ja ähm also man könnte merken, die halbe Welt mit den nur wenn die Rasenflächen mit Essen bepflanzen würde, könnte man schon äh ne also hätte man die halbe Welt äh mit irgendwie ähm,
verfüttern. Äh Rasen generell schlechte Idee, aber wenn man Rasen hat, einfach liegen lassen den Scheiß. Ja, da hast du vielleicht ein bisschen Moos drinnen, dann äh,
aber du musst halt auch nicht deinen Rasen. Ähm äh Rasen düngen, der Boden wird aufgebaut, was.
Hast Regenwürmer auf jeden Fall nichts gegen die Regenwürmer machen. Mittlerweile machen Leute wirklich was, weil die in die Häufchen stören, die Regenwürmer oben ab. Wirklich Mitte gegen Regenwürmer, nichts gegen die Regenwürmer machen, die fressen dann super gerne diese,
Rasenteile und machen dann mehr machen den Bodenaufbau. Generell Bodenaufbau, Hackschnitzel.
Aber auch abgestorbene Äste einfach liegen lassen, hinlegen, klein schneiden, umso kleiner man das schneiden kann, mit wenig Energieaufwand, umso besser, umso schneller äh verwittert es, umso mehr Bohnen baust du auf.
Also Häckseln und gleich wieder rauf.
Aber auch verschneiden reicht manchmal auch, wenn man jetzt nur so eine Hecke schneidet und das einfach liegen lassen. Ja oder irgendwo hintun, wo ihr ganz schlecht
Boden ist von mir aus auch noch so im innerhalb des Gartens so, ja. Ähm Bodenaufbau, Bodenauf, notfalls Kompost kommen lassen, wirklich Grünschnittkompost jedes
Kompostwerk hat zu viel Kompost. Das ist halt der Wahnsinn. Die Leute bringen den diesen Gartenabfälle in gerade hier im Speckgürtel sehr gerne. Bring den unendlich viele Rasen ab. Äh hier Gartenabfälle.
Können sich nicht retten, machen daraus Kompost und keiner will den haben. Ja, also die die türmen sich, diese diese äh Kompostberg.
Warum will das keiner haben.
Kompost kaufen dann auch manchmal Gartenerde, weil sie gerade eher neue Eigenheime gebaut haben und dann haben
gebaut haben, den ganzen Garten abgeschoben. Das äh sieht man jetzt sehr, sehr häufig. Äh ähm und dann holen sie sich wieder Gartenerde. Das ist ein bisschen Kompost reingemischt mittlerweile. Ähm.
Versuchen dann da ihren ihren Kontrollrasen draufzumachen. Ähm aber ansonsten Kompost.
Ist auch nicht teuer. Ja, also so ein Kubikkompass weiß nicht 5zehn Euro, zehn Euro, je nachdem wo man gerade ist. Äh Cookie-Kompass ist viel. Also ist richtig für so einen normalen Hausgarten, ne, also wenn du.
Wir reden dann eigentlich schon von Erde. Also wir reden von.
Kompostierte Gartenabfälle. Wir reden nicht äh Erde ist immer mit Sand oder äh mit einem sandigen Anteil. Wir reden wirklich von Reim,
kompostierten Garten abfällen, Grünschnittkompost. Auch um den Grünschnitt Kompost kein.
Tier, Abfall, Kompost, sage ich jetzt mal, also kein Scheiß, da Kompost von Pferden ganz schlecht.
Pferdemist auch ganz schlecht einzubringen, weil die werden entwurmt, das Entwurmungsmittel hält drei Jahre, machst du die ganzen Regenwürmer kaputt.
Ähm äh und ansonsten ist in diesem Kompost, der aus ähm Gülle kommt, äh sage ich mal, aus aus Kuh oder so ähm zu viel Fortsport drin, dann machst du dir zu viel Phospor am Boden, mach.
Ist wieder ein Spurenelement, Boa bindet Boa und hast kein Boa, kannst dir Gemüse anbauen, weil jedes Gemüse braucht Boah, als als Spurenelement.
Ja äh kompliziert aber Grünstückkompost kriegt man hier kriegt man überall ja also diese die man normalerweise in so einem Kompostwerk in so einem Erdenwerk,
ist auch ohne Zusätze, ohne Düngemittel, ohne alles einfach rauf da. Ja, der manchmal ist der nicht fertig, das ist auch egal, Hauptsache der Boden ist bedeckt,
nie offene Böden lassen. Das ist auch ein großer Tipp, den ich mitgeben kann. Je nach Böden, offene Wasserflächen schaffen, ist auch geil.
Ja, also von mir aus auch notfalls mal eine Teichfolie nehmen, um vom Regenrinn Rohr mal einen Naturteich zu machen. Äh besser sind dein Tonit Matten äh gibt's mittlerweile auch in.
Äh in ähm in handelsüblichen, also in in haushaltsüblichen Größen. Früher gab's die nur einen riesengroßen Matten mit irgendwie für riesen Teiche und Deponieabdeckung macht man damit und so. Das sind halt
zwei ähm zwei Matten, die werden aus.
Gesteinsfasern, das ist so was wie Dämmwolle, ja, werden die gewebt und dazwischen wird Bentonit, Betonit ist ein Tonmineral, was bis zu Zehnfaches seines Volums erreicht, wenn's mit Wasser in Kontakt,
und das wird dazwischen eingewebt. Das heißt auch, wenn da eine Wühlmaus kommt und von unten ein Loch macht, dichtet sich das Ding selber wieder ab. Je nach Lochgröße.
Aufgefällt. Also Oberflächenwasser schaffen ist cool, muss auch nicht groß sein. Ein kleiner Teich, mini Teich, notfalls auch eine Badewanne halt versenken oder so, ja? Kann ich äh macht ein ein Habitat im Garten.
Extrem viel. Ich habe hier so einen kleinen Betonteich, der war hier schon. Ja, so nicht groß, hier so. Ein Quadratmeter.
Alte Badewanne, so eine alte Metallbadewanne meinst du?
Ja, also egal was, Hauptsache irgendwas, was Wasser hält,
Lebewesen, die da rauskommen bei der Badewanne, muss man dann aufpassen, dass man irgendwie Bretter fliegt oder so, dass die nicht ertrinken da drinne.
Auch bepflanzen, schön irgendwie Teichrosen reinmachen, irgendwas, ja, sieht ja auch schön aus, äh aber für alle Insekten, Kröten, Amphibien, Vögel, als wirklich als als auch als ähm als Stille zum Trinken.
Unverzichtbar. Also irgendwas Kleines mit Wasser. Auch äh macht auch sofort feucht
rundrum. Ja, also sofort eine hohe Luftfeuchtigkeit rundrum, Verdunstung und so weiter. Natürlich umso größer das, größere Verdunstung, umso mehr Bewuchs auch drauf haben, damit die Verdunstung nicht so hoch ist, dass man nicht immer nachfühlen muss. In so einem trockenen Jahr,
Aber selbst wenn der mal austrocknet, auch nicht so schlimm, ja also die gibt's im Wald, gibt's ein paar Naturweiher, ja, die trocknen einmal im Jahr aus, also überhaupt kein Problem. Trotzdem super Bioversität drum rum und man merkt auch, da sind Insekten und alle zieht's dahin.
Ja det kann ich sehr empfehlen. Ähm Pilze etablieren.
Ja, also wenn man auch notfalls irgendwo mal mit C kauft und so da gibt's so ähm,
Beetpilze, Schwarmpilze ist so ein Beetpilz, wenn man heißt in Deutsch, Braunkappe, er hat sich 100 Braunkappen gibt, ist das,
der Name, aber kann man auch mal in Englisch googeln. Den gibt's auch, der in Kanick auch sehr empfehlen. Den mit reinwerfen. Zersetzen das wesentlich schneller,
wird man auch anorganischem Material raufwerft, dann kann man auch mal Holz raufwerfen. Ähm die zersetzen det dann gleich mit,
und äh machen durch det Myzelnetzwerk, das hättet Internet, det Waldes, ist aber nicht nur Internet, sondern auch det Internet das Gemüse betet.
Die tauschen Nährstoffe aus, Informationen tatsächlich, da ist irgendwie ein Predator dahinten, der wurde befallen, produzier du mal irgendwie.
Die Bäume machen.
Auch die Bäume machen, ja. Ähm also die dieser King Strafhoria, dieser ähm hat dann jetzt rausgefunden, dass der wirklich der.
Man den im Beet hat äh Gemüseertracht 30 Prozent mehr. Paul.
Stammens ist immer vielleicht alle, die Star Trek gucken, einen Begriff, ähm das tatsächlich.
Ähm auf einem original Charakter basierend der größte Pilzforscher, der auch sehr permakulturnah ist tatsächlich. Ähm
Ähm Paul Stamms kann ich sehr empfehlen, wenn man sich mit Pilzmeer auseinandersetzt und Pilze nicht vergessen. In diesem ganzen System Pilze nie vergessen. Pilze sind einfach.
Riesentreuling, sagt Wikipedia, ist ja.
Von mir aus auch Riesentäuschling, ja. Lange Zeit brauchen Kappe genannt, ja.
Ja Braunkappe ist hier auch äh so eine Handelsbezeichnung.
Genau. Wird ein riesengroßer Essbar, äh nicht äh nicht Essbar, wenn er riesengroßes Essen, wenn er rauskommt, super lecker. Wird ein äh alle Speisepilze halt auch wieder Ertrag
Äh der Ertrag eines Systems ist unbegrenzt, ist die äh ist das Prinzip vom ja? Auch da wieder Ertrag. Ich habe jetzt diese Pilze auch in diese,
mit Baumstämmen und Hackschnitzeln Wege gelegt, sprich, ich habe jetzt also da nicht nur Gemüse in den Wegen, äh in den Reihen, sondern ich habe in den Wegen auch noch einen Ertrag nämlich Pilze und die kommen und die ernt ich auch im Moment noch nicht genug vom Verkauf, aber für mich zum Essen erstmal ausreichen.
Ja ähm stecking functions.
Gar nicht mehr über deine Wege gehen, wenn da die Pilze wachsen.
Die wachsen auch immer mehr als begrenzt und die wachsen ja schnell, also Pilz zwei Tage, ne? Also
äh innerhalb der zwei Tage und essbare, da kannst du rumlatschen, ja. Und was rauskommt, ist ja ist ja nur die Frucht vom Pilze, es wird wirklich Pilze, es ist ja unterirdisch.
Ähm.
Nicht vergessen im System, Kompost abdecken, also nie offene Böden, nie nie umgraben, ich grabe nicht um.
Ja? Bei mir mein System ist,
habe einmal und ganz am Anfang, um jetzt so eine Wiese in in in ein in ein Gemüsebeet zu verwandeln, nehme ich einmal einen Rotationsflug, ob böse Böse ganz schlimm mit Gerät, machen mich alle Regenwürmer kaputt. Ich habe keine Regenwürmer in meinem
Boden. Wenn du vorher Regenwürmer habt, wo die Kinnrotationsflug nehmen, ähm
mit dem Handbaden für den Hausgebrauch geht es auch super. Doppel doppelt umgraben, sprich man nimmt.
Oberste Schicht weg und die und eine drunter und gräbt das da neben da rein, muss man mal googeln, doppelt umgraben, ähm doppelt oh wie heißt denn das, Doppelumgrabe.
Eine Doppelgrabe, Gabel, äh det ist zum Lüften, ist später. Wenn man Tonböden hat, braucht man dit vor allen Dingen, nein, macht det ooch einmal am Anfang, doppelt umgraben,
Ich komme gerade nicht drauf, aber es ist äh Prinzip, man nimmt die Rasenschicht raus aus so einer Reihe,
Spatentisch tief, legtet nach rechts. Dann gräbt man nochmal innen einen Stich tiefer, liegt auch nach rechts daneben und dann
nimmt man die Reihe daneben, also Reihe heißt Spartenreihe daneben und legt verkehrt rum, diese oberste Rasenschicht in diesen ersten Reihe rein.
Und dickt dann die Schicht da drunter, da oben rauf und so geht man durch det ganze Beet, bis man dann da angekommen ist, wo man die erste Schicht hingelegt hat und,
die dann auch wieder rein und hat sozusagen zwei Spatenstich zu umgegraben. Hat erstmal ein schönes Beet, kein,
nix kaputt gemacht, ne Schwarten macht man jetzt nicht so. Kann ja sein, dass man mal einen Regenbogen zerstört, weil man den durchgetrennt hat, der hat dann halt Pech gehabt. Ja, aber,
Genau, hat erstmal nichts kaputt gemacht und äh unten hat man schon so organische Substanz drin, ja? Und die Zweitspartenstich tief, dass schon weniger Unkräuter drin,
So und wenn man jetzt wirklich so ein Bild anlegt zu Hause.
Pappe drauf, feuchte Pappe, nasse Pappe, wirklich in der Badewanne, in einer alten oder in einem Trog richtig nass machen, drauflegen, nie trocken
wird nie wieder nass. Unten drunter wird nie wieder nass, sondern trockene Pappe aufgelegt. Ich habe zwei Jahre später halt durch. Ja, also macht ja Fehler und wir müssen gemacht.
Was bringt die Pappe dann.
Unkrautunterdrückung. Äh du hast zwei Unkreuz äh Arten, einmal,
Samen, Saat und Kraut und ein Aerosol. Äh beides kriegst du durch die Pappe erst äh erstmal unterdrückt. Äh lange genug,
dass sie auch absterben, die die äh und die ähm Samen,
Samenunkraut kämmt gar nicht erst, weil kann ich keinem vielleicht, aber kriege kein Licht, kann ich hoch, stirbt ab. Und auf die Pappe macht man Kompost.
Gibt's da noch verschiedene Sorten, äh verschiedene Sachen, was man noch machen kann? Man kann da auch noch wie so ein Lasagne mehrere Stufen reinbringen, aber
Wer jetzt so wegen so einem Gemüsebeet anlegen würde, wenn ich jetzt so ein normales Ding hätte. So ist jetzt ähm
ja und wenn man dann länger Gemüse hat, wird länger draufsteht, also nicht so einen Salat, der nach vier Wochen wieder runter ist. Aber wenn man jetzt so,
Paprika hat oder so, die wirklich die ganze Saison draufstehen, dann würde ich auch noch so Hackschnitzel nehmen, ja, vielleicht noch irgendeine Düngung, aber jetzt nicht.
Sondern irgendwie Hühner-Mist oder so.
Um, also nur, wenn man Hackschnitzel oben raufpackt, weil der zieht so viel äh Stickstoff aus dem Boden, dass so eine extra Düngung noch mal wichtig ist. Ähm ick hier mit meinen vier Kulturen muss schon auch.
Hühnermist und Tauben ist aus dem Nachbardorf, da ist wieder Permakultur, gucken,
wird im Außenbereich in den Randzonen so an Ressourcen da sind, ja? Da habe ich festgestellt, hier gibt's einen Taubenzüchter, der ist total lieb, der liebt seine Tauben, füttert ihn irgendwie
Bio essen. Äh findet jetzt äh der für Hochzeitstauben hat er lange gemacht. Jetzt durch Corona kann er keine Hochzeitsturm machen, deswegen macht er jetzt Flugtauben.
Ne, ist ja auch anpassungsfähig hier auf dem Land und der würde für seinen Mist bezahlen, wenn er den ähm Kompostwerk abliefert,
Kompostwerk darf das ja nicht abnehmen, weil du das Tier misst. Eigentlich muss er den spezial kompostieren selber. Dazu müsst ihr wieder eine Betonwander gießen und so weiter. Und der ist total happy. Ich darf's als Dünger benutzen, bestimmten,
in bestimmten Mengen und äh kriegt.
Einfach weil die Taubenscheiße einfach das wiederum.
Ist geil.
Ja, also Taubscheiße ist also überhaupt Hühner-Mist ist äh Hühnermist, ist auch cool. Also Vogel, Vogelscheiß ist besser als ähm Wiederkäuer. Und so weit viel mehr drin ist, viel mehr die nutzen nicht so viel davon,
auf sich nehmen, aber äh zersetzen das erstmal. Ja. Genau.
Ich sehe schon. Die Liste äh ist potenziell unendlich und die Auseinandersetzung mit dem Thema äh.
Ja Werkzeuge, genau.
Endlich auch lang so. Also es kommt dann immer wieder was Neues bei raus.
Ja, wir könnten hier noch wir könnten ja bestimmt zwanzig so eine Dinge erfüllen, ne? Also es ist äh.
Solche Podcasts meinst du, ja? Oha.
Ja also wir haben ja nicht mal die Grenze, wir haben nicht mal das Ohr. Äh was ich noch werde ich gerne.
Da musst du dann deinen eigenen Podcast aufmachen. Das wäre wahrscheinlich genau das Richtige an der Stelle.
Ist äh wichtig gearbeitet daran. Ähm eine Sache die ich noch jetzt noch zu kurz komme ist ähm also äh wir haben in der Permakultur jetzt wirklich drei drei also
kurz erwähnt, aber ich,
muss noch mal drauf eingehen. Wir haben wirklich drei äh Produktionsstufen durch. Die Erstheimer Kultur ist zügig diese landbasierte, über die wir jetzt auch hauptsächlich geredet haben. Ähm das hatte in den neunziger Jahren wirklich diesen
absoluten Schwenk in diese soziale Permakultur gemacht. Da habe ich auch schon ein bisschen mehr drauf eingegangen. Aber wir sind jetzt wirklich an dem dritten Punkt und das ist dieses lebenden Designpro,
weil wir gemerkt haben, wir arbeiten mit einem lebenden System und wir können nicht
ein großes Design machen, was im Business Detail ausgearbeitet ist von außen da drauf schmeißen, dit,
stur umsetzen und dann kommt da schon das Richtige bei raus. Das hat sich herausgestellt, das funktioniert so nicht. Ähm mal abgesehen, dass Menschen sich permanent verändern, verändert sich auch diese Natur permanent. Sprich's äh.
Ähm wo wir jetzt sind, sondern lebenden Designprozess, also für einen wirklich ein paar mal gute Designer, der woanders hinkommt. Der muss wirklich Permakultur unterrichten. Das ist eher so ein Permakultur unter Teacher geworden als einen äh äh als einen Designer.
Muss den Leuten beibringen, die auf diesem Land sind, äh wie sie selber für sich ein Design, ein gutes Design machen. Man kann so grobe Framework,
erstellen, wo dann ausgefüllt wird, aber ähm ja, dieser lebende Designprozess ist jetzt Permakultur drei Punkt null, ähm ist ganz, ganz wichtig, alle, die sich damit beschäftigen,
Es ist äh ist ganz frisch
äh Making Primark culture stronger ist da der Podcast dazu für Leute, die wirklich da tiefer einsteigen wollen und die vielleicht von der Permakultur kommen, kann ich ganz doll empfehlen, weil der Typ, was der da sagt,
fürs Überleben der Permakultur auch ganz wichtig, weil der hat ein bisschen stagniert jetzt auch, weil viele Projekte auch gescheitert sind. Ähm.
Äh weil sie halt diesen starren Designprozess gemacht haben und dieser Feedback-Look, auf den ich jetzt auch noch gar nicht gekommen bin, ne, also beobachten, Analyse, Design, Feedback ist jetzt der Feedback-Loop.
Existiert jetzt schon auch während des Designprozesses. Ja also dieser Feedback und Design, das wird jetzt so eins, weil wir gucken jetzt während des Designs, was wirklich funktioniert. Ähm und füllen all diese Framework, also diese grobe
Klar, da kommt irgendwo der Bach an. Da,
ist schon klar, da ist dann da vielleicht und da gibt's dann die Einstell, wo man einen Damm baut. Da muss ich kein lebendes Design machen, ne? Aber äh wie ich den Damm bepflanze nachher, ja? Ähm
äh Dammbau ist jetzt in Deutschland auch nicht so das Hauptthema, weil wir wenig
wenig so Flächen haben, wo wo Dämme gebaut aber in Australien ist viel. Deswegen jetzt so als Beispiel. Ähm.
Ne, aber was, wie man den bepflanzt und so weiter oder wie der sich auch erst mal erst mal zu gucken, was der Damm überhaupt mit seiner Umgebung macht, ja und dann das Design daran hin anzupassen. Das ist so dieses Leben, eine Designprozess und,
Schöne ist, dass Permacoote sich selbst als und das möchte so äh Abschluss nehmen, sich selbst als,
komplexes System sieht und sich selbst designt und auch weiterentwickelt. Das habe ich auch selten dann irgendwo anders erlebt
ja viele sind erst da und auch in ihren Vorstellungen und wird nicht weiterentwickelt und man hält daran fest und dit ist Permakultur überhaupt nicht. Es entwickelt für lebende Design und begreift sich selbst auch als lebende.
Für lebende Systeme und begreift dich selbst auch als Lebenssystem. Und äh entwickelt sich immer weiter und das macht et auch so unheimlich schön und spannend und komplex.
Super. Falk. Ähm dem habe ich jetzt nicht mehr viel äh hinzuzufügen.
Würde sagen, vielen Dank für die Ausführung. Es war eine schöne Reise durch die äh Permakultur. Ich werde mir jetzt gleich noch mal hier die Beete äh anschauen. Gucken, ob ich mir unseren Laden.
Tim ist April. Ja ja.
Wenn die so lange halten du bist doch noch einer vom letzten Jahr da sein.
Ist eine Frühlingshilfe vom letzten Jahr, kannste noch mitnehmen, aber ja.
Na gut, okay, vielen Dank und vielen Dank fürs Zuhören. Das war's bei CRE. Ich sage äh tschüss und.